Chomp!
Ja ich bin da, oh mein Mikrofon ist wieder zu laut.
Und wisst ihr warum mein Mikrofon zu laut ist?
Wer rät es als erstes, da kommt ihr nie drauf.
Mein Mikrofon ist zu laut, weil Teams wieder dran rumgestellt hat.
Genau.
Weil Teams dran rumgestellt hat.
Und Teams bedeutet auch, ich musste euch wieder arbeiten.
Und was meint ihr, wie sehr ich darauf Bock hatte, heute morgen aufzustehen und arbeiten zu gehen?
Wobei zu gehen ist übertrieben.
Michael 50 Billionen, gehen ist übertrieben.
Ich musste ja eigentlich nur ins Arbeitszimmer rüber.
Und das ist exakt da, wo ich jetzt auch sitze.
Oder auch exakt da, wo ich die ganze Zeit gesessen habe, als ich Urlaub hatte.
Aber es ist doch ein Unterschied.
Es ist schon was anderes.
Ob man aufsteht um 8 oder um halb 8.
Und dann rüber geht an den Rechner und irgendwie Stream macht.
Oder irgendwie YouTube Zeug macht.
Oder einfach nur irgendwas anderes macht.
Oder ob man sich dann mit Teams Messages oder irgendwelchen Tickets
oder Leuten, die heute Wartungsarbeit ankündigen wollen,
oder was auch immer auseinandersetzen muss.
Ja, ich habe ja immer die Ehre.
Weiß ich, ob ich das schon mal erzählt habe.
Wir haben so ein Master, ich weiß gar nicht, wie das offiziell heißt.
So Master Change Meeting.
Da kommt einer aus jedem Team, aus jeder Abteilung.
Und das sind ganz schön viele.
Ich glaube, da sind mittlerweile über 60 Leute eingeladen.
Und die erzählen dann, was sie für Changes vorhaben.
Und ihr könnt euch vorstellen, das artet teilweise extrem in Monologe
und Cool Story Bro aus.
Wolle604, danke für den Sub.
Ich mache das...
Oh, Moment, mein Mikrofonkabel.
Leute, weil es letztens irgendeiner mal wieder gekleppt hat,
das hier ist nicht ins Mikrofon furzen.
Das ist der Reißverschluss von meinem Hemd, was ich an habe.
Oh.
Es gab ja wirklich ein Clip, Max furzt ins Mikrofon.
Da hört man, wie das Mikrofon am Reißverschluss reibt.
Jaja.
Zoomer Vorstellung wieder hier.
Hemd mit Reißverschluss.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, wie ich das sonst nennen soll.
Es ist nicht wirklich ein Hemd, so was, was ich auf die Arbeit anziehe.
Okay, vielleicht ist es auch eher so eine ärmellose Weste.
Aber auf jeden Fall hat es einen Reißverschluss.
Ja.
Und Leute, ich kann euch sagen, auf dieser Wartungsrunde,
das dreht sich teilweise so extrem im Kreis,
das ist extremst langweilig.
Da kommt der erste und sagt, ja, wir würden gerne hier zwei Kabel stecken.
So, da kommt der nächste und sagt, da hätte ich aber mal eine Frage dazu.
Steckt ihr die Kabel links rum, rechts rum oder 45 Grad verdreht rein?
Da muss ich mal Rücksprache halten mit dem, mit dem der den Change umsetzt.
Habt ihr denn dazu auch ein Change Ticket erstellt?
Wie sieht es aus?
Habt ihr ein Rollback Verfahren?
Ja, Rollback Verfahren ist, wir stecken den Stecker 90 Grad rein.
Ist das auch ein getestetes Rollback Verfahren?
Bei euch heißt das Change Advisory Board.
Ja, ich glaube, so ähnlich heißt das bei uns auch.
Nee, die gucken wir uns nicht an, aber das habe ich gelesen.
Das habe ich gelesen.
Aber es ist immer so Pains Champ diese Runde,
weil es nicht vorwärts geht.
Und kennt ihr Leute, die einfach aus Prinzip immer Rückfragen haben,
ohne dass sie wirklich Rückfragen haben?
Ich sehe, ihr kennt euch mit Change Advisory Boards aus.
Mich hat mal tatsächlich, ohne Scheiß, das ist kein Witz, Leute.
Kein Witz.
Kein Spaß hier.
Wir hatten mal einen Change, da ging es darum,
wir mussten auf einen Fileserver gehen, weil Mist,
also waren falsche Sachen drinne.
Und wir mussten Dateien löschen.
Also nichts Wildes.
Du lockst dich ein per SSH, gehst ins richtige Verzeichnis,
machst einen RM, die Dateien sind weg,
und dann ist gut.
Du musst doch nicht mal was neu starten oder sonst was.
Und da wurden wir allen Ernstes gefragt,
macht ihr das im 4-Augen-Verfahren?
Da habe ich mir gedacht,
weiß ich, ob wir für eine Sache, die 5 Sekunden dauert,
um 23 Uhr 2 Leute hinsetzen wollen anstatt 1.
Ja, aber 4-Augen-Verfahren, da könnt ihr das falsche löschen.
Also wenn man da vor Angst hat,
der kann ja den Befehl vorher eingeben,
und dann guckt man nochmal mit drauf,
und um 23 Uhr schickt ihr es dann ab.
Und dann kam der nächste,
und das ist jetzt das erste,
dass wir den 4-Augen-Verfahren beim Löschen,
das kann ich ja noch verstehen,
aber sobald so Diskussionen einmal anfangen,
hören die Diskussionen dann nicht auf,
dann kam der nächste, und das ist uns ungelogen,
ist kein Witz.
Da hat er gefragt, gibt es ein Rollback-Verfahren?
Mit einem LS und einem RM hinten dran.
Ich wusste nicht, was ich sagen soll.
Das Einzige, was ich gesagt habe, ist, wir haben Backups.
Ja, ja, genau.
Dass diese Files aber gar nicht gebackt haben,
ist wieder was anderes.
Rollback-Verfahren, wollten sie wissen.
So, und danach ging das Ganze noch weiter.
Du darfst dir bei diesen Boards keine Plöße geben.
Du musst immer so klingen, als wüsstest du,
von was du sprichst, auch wenn du keine Ahnung hast.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das jemand auch schon mal
die Erfahrung gemacht hat,
aber sobald es so klingt, als bist du nicht
hundertprozentig davon überzeugt,
als wüsstest du exakt, was du sagst,
kommt aus jeder Ecke irgendeiner,
ich hätte doch mal eine Rückfrage,
wie sieht es denn damit aus?
Habt ihr das auch damit geklärt?
Habt ihr dir Hotline-Bescheid gesagt?
Dann nerven die, sobald einer nervt, nerven alle.
So, und das ging ja noch weiter.
Ich habe gestottert darauf hin,
ich habe gesagt, wie Rollback-Verfahren,
wir gehen da drauf, SSH, LS,
gucken im Verzeichnis, was da so drin ist,
dann gehen wir hin, mal löschen das.
Ich war schon ein paar Jahre hier,
ist nicht super aktuell, ja.
Und das haben die gemerkt,
die haben uns gemerkt, dass ich kurz gezögert habe.
Und daraufhin kommen sie da an mit,
gibt es ein Rollback-Verfahren,
und dann kam noch der Hit, das ging noch weiter.
Das ist noch nicht zu Ende gewesen mit Rollback-Verfahren.
Dann kam wirklich jemand, hat gefragt,
habt ihr denn dafür auch die Gefahren-Matrix ausgefüllt?
Kennt ihr eine Gefahren-Matrix?
Weiß gar nicht, ob so was...
Gefahren-Matrix?
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es so was,
ob das was ist, was wir uns ausgedacht haben,
oder ob das was ist, was es wirklich...
Ja, so sieht das bei uns aus in die Richtung.
Aber halt nicht für...
Also, nicht dafür.
So, und wobei das nicht ganz stimmt,
wir haben eine Gefahren-Matrix,
die ist so...
Die geht so von links oben nach rechts unten,
und wenn die passenden Punkte zusammen ausgewählt werden,
ist es sehr kritisch.
So.
Und da mussten wir allen Ernstes...
Ich weiß nicht, was das hier sein soll.
Ja, so was...
So was ähnlich...
So was ähnlich ist das.
So sieht das ähnlich, sieht das bei uns auch aus.
Ja, du kannst in unserer Gefahren-Matrix zum Beispiel
ankreuzen,
ist ein User betroffen,
sind viele User betroffen,
sind alle User betroffen,
und dann so nach dem Motto,
ruckeln,
Teilausfall, oder alles ist weg,
und so was nach dem Motto.
Und wenn du dann zum Beispiel sagst,
es sind alle betroffen, aber auch nur ein bisschen,
dann kann das sehr hoch sein,
und es ist nur ein User betroffen,
das ist ultra wichtig, und es geht gar nichts mehr,
dann kann das auch so hoch sein, also Gefahren-Matrix.
Und da mussten wir allen Ernstes, das ist kein Spaß,
eine Gefahren-Matrix ausfüllen
für eine LS und RM auf einem Server.
Und da mussten wir dann durch Fragen beantworten,
gibt es ein Rollback-Verfahren.
Also wirklich, das ist teilweise echt,
da wird sich zu Tode
gemanagt, bei diesen Sachen.
Ja, es ist echt so, aber ich muss sagen,
jetzt müsstest du da eigentlich bleiben,
müsstest du da eigentlich mal bringen, direkt.
Was, Rollback?
Ich roll gleich deine Mutter.
Ja, mal gucken, je nachdem wer dabei ist,
je nachdem wer dabei ist, kann man das sagen,
ohne Konsequenzen, oder man ist direkt weg,
kommt drauf an.
Ja, aber mittlerweile muss ich sagen,
ich hab das jetzt eigentlich halbwegs gut raus,
wie man solche Runden handelt.
Und zwar, ich mach das immer folgendermaßen,
ich guck mir die Changes an,
die da eingetragen sind von uns,
also für die, die ich da verdrehte,
ja, und meistens
mach ich da raus ein
Standard-Change,
haben wir schon 100 Mal gemacht,
geht nichts kaputt bei.
Das ist im Prinzip legit,
dass in irgendeine Abwandlung,
ist das, was ich zu jedem Change
von uns sage mittlerweile.
Standard-Change habe ich schon 100 Mal gemacht,
gibt keine Probleme.
Der Witz ist,
das ist so kurz und knapp,
da hat nie jemand Rückfragen.
Sobald du Details nennst,
kommen die Leute um die Ecke und sagen,
ah, wie sieht es aus, habt ihr den informiert,
habt ihr den informiert, habt ihr den informiert,
aber wenn du einfach nur sagst,
Standard-Change zum Beispiel,
was wir immer ganz gerne machen,
ist, dass ablaufende Zertifikate
müssen getauscht werden
und es gibt durchaus
Kisten, da ist das nicht ganz unkritisch,
wenn Zertifikate getauscht werden,
beispielsweise, wenn das
irgendwelche Loadbalancer ganz am Eingang sind
und die im Zweifelfall
irgendwie reloaded werden müssen oder so,
wo es dann tatsächlich mal vielleicht
2-3 Sekunden ruckelt, aber halt für
alles, was ich in dem Moment verbinden will.
Das sage ich auch mittlerweile,
Standard-Change ist ja
auch beim Change-Management bekannt,
haben wir schon oft gemacht, das bewährt das Verfahren,
Standard-Change-Verfahren
heute Nacht, 23 Uhr.
Da sagt keiner was dazu.
Die gucken sich das nämlich
alle nicht an. Hinten steht genau
drin, dass es kurz ruckeln kann,
aber die genehmigen das trotzdem.
Und sobald du irgendwie einen Change hast,
der total unwichtig ist,
aber versuchst ihn zu erklären,
kommen sie aus alle Ecken und nerven dann
rum. Also das ist ganz, ganz wild.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass diese Runde
irgendwie das bringt, was man sich so
vorstellt.
Übrigens, ich muss mal kurz das Betriebssystem
Update machen, fällt mir gerade auf.
Das wollte ich eigentlich schon starten, aber
habe ich irgendwie nicht dran gedacht.
Checking for Updates, ja, checke mal.
Es gibt keine Updates.
Ja, benutze ich selbst.
Du kannst ja an meinen Repos
machen, ne? Wir patchen heute nochmal was
in Uptime-Kuma rein.
Nämlich das zweite, was ich haben will.
Nachdem das erste nicht so ganz ausgereifter war,
was ich gemacht habe, da machen wir eine Zertifikatsübersicht,
wann die ablaufen. Es gibt zwei Sachen,
die ich haben will. Zertifikatsübersicht
und in Push-Notifications
was anderes als Ping-Werte.
Aber wir machen mal eine Zertifikatübersicht.
ITIL4 ist schon Hyper-Age,
da ist jetzt Change-Enablement
... ist das jetzt
ein Witz? Oder ist das ernst?
Ich bin mir da nicht mehr
so sicher mittlerweile.
Jett, ist das ein Witz oder ist das ernst?
Change-Enable,
die benennen auch einfach
Randomized immer irgendwelche Dinge um, oder?
Change-Enable...
Die haben wirklich Probleme.
Die haben ja nichts anderes zu tun.
Wisst ihr, was auch immer
witzig ist?
Machen immer alle
so super krass ausgeklügelte
Prozesse,
die sich teilweise über, wenn du den ausdrucken würdest,
die sich teilweise wahrscheinlich
einmal rund im Raum über die Wand
erstrecken würden. Kennt ihr aus dem Mittelalter
diese Wandteppiche, die irgendwelche
was weiß ich, der König schlägt,
eine Schlachtgeschichte erzählen?
Diese Wandteppiche, die einmal so quasi durch die gesamte
Burg durchgehen. Ungefähr so
so einen Teppich bräuchtest du auch,
wenn du manche unserer Prozesse
ausdrucken wolltest. Aber
der Witz daran ist immer,
da werden sich die krassesten Prozesse
und Dinge ausgedacht, aber
sobald das erste
Mal irgendwas
da nicht funktioniert,
wird nicht etwa gesagt, okay,
dann müsste man vielleicht mal den Prozess
überdenken, also so wie es sein sollte,
da wird dann gesagt, ne, ne, ne, ne,
das ist Vorstandentscheidung oder was weiß ich,
Führungsmanagemententscheidung,
wir umgehen jetzt den Prozess und machen das
händisch.
Und da denke ich mir auch immer, wenn man jeden
kurz händisch macht,
da kann man sich doch nicht drauf berufen, man hat irgendwelche
Prozesse, die angeblich funktionieren, weil die
funktionieren nicht, und anstatt zu sagen
und man zuzugeben, dass sie nicht funktionieren,
macht man das funktioniert, aber ganz
anders.
Also das ist teilweise
echt wir.
Ach ja, und ich habe mitbekommen, dass einer bei uns
der maßgeblich für irgendwelche
Prozesse und Abläufe verantwortlich war,
der wurde rausgeschmissen,
also Ende des Jahres,
und der andere wurde versetzt,
falsches Emote,
weil, jetzt kommt's,
sie beim
Erstellen der Prozesse zu viel unangenehme
Fragen aufgeworfen haben
und zu sehr genervt haben.
Ich muss dir mal vorstellen,
die Leute, hallo, als
Prozessmanager und Koordinator
wirst du bezahlt zum Nerven.
Das ist dein Job,
da kannst du die Leute nicht rausschmeißen, sie gingen ja auch
auf den Sack, aber da kannst du die Leute
doch nicht rausschmeißen, wenn sie ihre Arbeit machen.
Ich weiß nicht, und
ach, das ist eh so
ein komischer Laden, wir sind halt
typisch Frankfurt Bank oder zu typisch
Bank, wir wollen nach außen hin
modern sein, sind aber innen
drinnen der größte Dinosaurier, den
zu gibt. So wie
Fat Yoshi sind wir. Wir
tun so, als wären wir besser, agiler
und moderner, aber wir sind's nicht.
Die beste Aussage
kann man, es wurde
bei uns mal so eine Umfrage gemacht,
da war sogar, glaub, der
TÜV da damals, da ging es
irgendwie um Burnout und Arbeitssicherheit
und sowas in der Richtung.
Da wurde zumindest
eine Umfrage
gemacht, bei den eigenen
Mitarbeitern, zu solchen Sachen
wie Arbeitsbelastung
und Hörungskräfte
und
Arbeitsmaterialien und sowas,
sowas in der Richtung, wurde eine Umfrage gemacht
und die Umfrage
ist jetzt ja egal, ob jetzt was da rausgekommen ist,
zumindest, in der
Präsentation
ist aufgefallen, dass wir anscheinend,
also das
Fazit dieser Umfrage, war wohl relativ
eindeutig, dass wir doch nicht so
geil sind, wie wir uns das immer einreden.
Was hat man daraufhin gemacht?
Die Umfragen waren alle
anonym, klar, sonst hätte ich dauernd mitgemacht.
Zumindest kamen die Umfragen raus, dass wir vielleicht
doch nicht so extrem
die geilsten, der
geil, der besten, der besten sind, als man sich
das immer ausmalt.
Und
deswegen hat man sich eine Vergleichsstatistik
anonymisiert eingekauft
und man hat nicht über unsere Ergebnisse
gesprochen, sondern
man hat immer nur über die Ergebnisse gesprochen
im Vergleich, wie viel besser
das zur gegenüber
gestellten Umfrage ist.
Also man hat nicht gesagt,
hier bei uns sieht es so und so aus,
sondern man hat bei jedem Punkt quasi
gesagt, wir sind so viel besser
als die anderen
und die anderen hast du halt irgendwie random
Vergleichsmaterial eingekauft, was besonders schlecht war.
So, es kam aber
trotzdem ein paar Punkte raus,
wo wir halt wirklich nicht gut waren.
Und
ähm,
es ist echt so.
Es kam aber trotzdem ein paar Sachen raus, wo
rausgekommen ist, da sind wir echt
nicht so gut.
So.
Und da wurde dann
gesagt, ja ok,
da wird sich jetzt per Taskforce
oder was auch immer drum gekümmert
und ein halbes Jahr später,
wisst ihr, was das Fazit
dieser Taskforce war?
Wir wissen
um unsere Schwächen.
Das war ernsthaft das Fazit
der Taskforce.
Wir wissen um unsere Schwächen.
Also ich meinte, ich wusste um unsere Schwächen vorher auch schon.
Da hätte ich die Taskforce nicht gebraucht.
Also ich sag euch Leute,
Business
Welt ist weit weg von
Logik und
normale Bedenken und sowas.
Der hätte das
geregelt, ja.
Im Prinzip, im Prinzip
ist das so, ja.
Warum hast du dich eigentlich für deinen Arbeitgeber entschieden?
Dazu habe ich mal ein Video gemacht.
Eine Kündigung?
Ja, ja guck mal.
Ich habe ein Video gemacht, warum ich
beim Provider, wo ich davor gearbeitet habe,
gekündigt habe und am Ende
erzähle ich auch glaube ich kurz was, warum ich da hingegangen bin,
wo ich jetzt bin.
Das liegt daran, weil
ich als ich noch beim Provider
gearbeitet habe, haben die uns verkauft.
Das hört sich jetzt nur nach
Menschenhandel an, aber ganz ehrlich,
ist es ja im Prinzip auch so
in der Richtung.
Die haben uns quasi verkauft
an diese Bank in Frankfurt, damals
noch für die Betreuung vom Rechenzentrum.
Als wir dann gesagt haben,
also bei dieser
Welle, wo ich dann auch dabei war, wo viele Leute gesagt haben,
ich habe keinen Bock mehr auf den Laden, wo ich auch dabei war
und gesagt habe Leute, ich kündige jetzt.
Da lief das eigentlich ganz gut, da hat nämlich die Bank
in Frankfurt gesagt, ja Jungs, wenn ihr eh kündigen wollt
dort, da kommt doch einfach direkt
zu uns.
Dann macht ihr einfach das gleiche,
wie ihr dort macht,
ihr bekommt bei uns mehr Geld
und wir sparen insgesamt noch Geld.
Weil wenn du dir irgendeinen Experte
einkaufst von einem Dienstleister,
ist es natürlich um vielfach teurer,
auch wenn du dem mehr bezahlst
als sonst.
Und daraufhin hat man das
gemacht.
Und da bin ich
dahin gewechselt.
Wie kann es sein, dass Strato
Linux V-Server mit 8 GB
RAM, 300 GB SSD und
4 CPU Core für 5, ja vielleicht ist das
ein Scherz.
Vielleicht ist das ein Scherz.
Kann das sein, vielleicht ist das ein Scherz.
Also bei Hetzner,
übrigens Ausrufezeichen Hetz,
ach Moment,
Ausrufezeichen Hetzner funktioniert ja
überhaupt nicht mehr. Mein Code
ist ja abgelaufen.
Hier, da muss ich mal meinen neuen Code kümmern,
mal gucken, wie es da aussieht.
Zumindest bei Hetzner kostet die
Quadcore Kiste 14 Euro im Monat.
Also ich muss sagen, 5 Euro
pro Monat, hast du mal einen Link dazu?
Hast du mal einen Link zu
dem Kram?
Säck, ich muss kurz muten.
Exzellent, funktioniert wieder.
Bald Hetzner ist er laut,
ja wird mal wieder Zeit, ich muss mir einen neuen Code
besorgen. So,
5 Euro ist tatsächlich ziemlich günstig,
ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es vielleicht
Schert ist.
Dass das quasi,
ob es auf einem ESX läuft oder auf einem KVM
läuft oder was auch immer,
dass es auf irgendeiner
Schert, die Frage ist, ob es überhaupt
eine echte VM ist oder irgendeinen Containerkrempel,
kann ja auch sein, dass man dort
Containerkram als V-Server verkauft,
oder dass die noch
Open, wie heißt das Zeug von früher,
OpenVZ oder so Dinger machen.
Zumindest kann sein, dass es
geschert ist, dass du
keine 8 Gigabyte und das garantiert
bekommst, sondern dass dein System
erkennt, dass das drinne ist,
aber wenn viel Andrang ist,
dass du dir das dann trotzdem teilst,
das ist ja dann
nicht falsch, dass das da steht?
Ich weiß es nicht, ich vermute jetzt einfach.
Würdest du gerne für EnoTrix arbeiten?
Nein, wie kommst du da drauf?
Hä?
Ich würde vielleicht mit dem Kasten
was aufnehmen, wenn wir irgendein gutes Thema haben,
weil das hatten wir nämlich vor, keine Ahnung,
10 Jahren oder so mal vor
und irgendwie habe ich mich nicht mal gemeldet,
deswegen ist das im Sand verlaufen.
Wenn wir ein gutes Thema hätten, würde ich vielleicht mit ihm arbeiten,
aber für ihn arbeiten nicht, nein.
Außerdem als was?
Als
Whirlpool
Keine Ahnung.
Damenbeglücker oder so,
weiß ich nicht, was er da früher von Dinger immer erzählt hat
in seinen Videos.
Hey, kennst du Leute, hast du Arbeitskollegen, die bei einem Bootcamp waren
und hast dort Coden gelernt haben?
Ähm, hast du das nicht schon mal gefragt?
Nein, kenne ich keine,
die in einem Bootcamp das gelernt haben.
Bei der Oracle Cloud gibt es 4 Core,
24 GB RAM, einfach umsonst
und das ist
komplett ohne Shared
oder was, das wäre ganz schön krass.
Geil und gut.
Schick mal Link, wenn du was hast, gucken wir uns an.
Stratowinsel
Ach ja, oh Gott, Open4Z,
dann ist das gar keine VM im eigentlichen Sinn.
Dann ist das quasi der Containervorgänger
von eingebauten
Linux-Containern.
Das ist so ein uraltes Linux, darauf kannst du überhaupt nichts machen.
Kein Wunder, dass das so billig ist.
Das ist ein Kernel 2.6
oder sowas.
Falls das das ist, weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Wahrscheinlich.
Wie kann man das umstellen
auf einen Monat?
Moment.
Wo ist es denn?
Ok, 6 Euro pro Monat.
Das ist bestimmt.
Containerstells,
Open4Z oder sowas.
Steht da? Gibt es da irgendwie mehr Infos dazu?
Gibt es da irgendwo Infos zu,
was das ist?
Nee, nicht wirklich, oder?
Das sind aber Armcores.
Ja ok.
Gibt es da irgendwie mehr?
Gibt es da irgendwie mehr Infos
zu bei Strato,
was das ist?
Haben die da irgendwas Hilfe?
Scroll mal runter.
Ah hier.
8 A, also 4 Kerne.
Was ist...
Wenn das ein echter VM ist,
kann ich darauf machen, was ich will.
Docker ready?
Wenn es ein VM ist, sollte das auch ohne Frage...
Die haben immer noch ihr altes,
gepatchtes Ding, oder?
Mit uralt Kernel.
Ja, das ist Open4Z
oder sowas.
Ja, da bekommst du
auf einer Kiste,
das ist quasi eher ein Container,
als eine richtige VM.
Ja gut, dann erklärts das auch,
warum das so günstig ist.
Und das hier,
ich weiß gar nicht, ob es noch
Patches gibt.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es
Open4Z Patches für Ubuntu gibt,
oder ob die das selbst maintainen, oder sowas.
Das ist ja egal, ob die
shared sind, dass der Hypervisor shared ist.
Solange das nicht
overloaded, extrem ist, macht das nichts.
Hier hast du halt das Problem, dass es
keine vollwertige VM ist, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Und dementsprechend
paar Sachen nicht machen kannst.
Und 100 MBit
ist jetzt auch nicht die Welt.
Ja, müsste man sich mal angucken,
aber es hat sicherlich seinen Haken, dass das
günstiger ist, als bei anderen.
So, ok, also
jetzt machen wir mal die Sache, hat er jetzt updated?
Ich reboote mal kurz
meine Linux Kiste, bevor wir anfangen.
Was war die Frage?
Was segen?
Hat was gefragt.
Was ist denn jetzt eigentlich
Shitia?
Also den Unterschied zwischen
Git und GitHub habe ich verstanden, also
das ist eigentlich ganz einfach.
Wenn du den Unterschied zwischen
Git und GitHub kennst,
dann weißt du ja, dass Git das eigentliche
Versionsverwaltungstool ist und GitHub
eigentlich nur ein Webinterface.
Also Git und GitHub hat eigentlich technisch
miteinander gar nichts zu tun.
Das ist ein Webinterface.
Und Git ist das eigentliche
Kommandozeilen bzw. das eigentliche
Sourcecode-Verwaltungstool.
Natürlich hat GitHub insofern was miteinander zu tun,
dass es für Git Repos gemacht ist,
aber das ist ein Webinterface. Früher mal
auf Ruby und Rails Basis, wie es jetzt bei GitHub
aussieht, keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich immer noch.
Weiß ich, ob ihr das geändert habt. So, wenn du den Unterschied
zwischen Git und GitHub kennst und dementsprechend
weißt, dass GitHub nur ein Webinterface ist,
dann ist Bitbucket auch nur ein Webinterface,
Git Lab auch nur ein Webinterface
und Git Thea oder Gox auch nur
ein Webinterface.
Du magst den Vergleich mit Porn und Pornhub.
Das ist tatsächlich ein ziemlich guter Vergleich.
Dann ist in dem Fall
ist
Git ist Porn und GitHub
ist Pornhub. So.
Und
Git Lab ist X Video
und Bitbucket
ist, was gibt es denn da noch alles?
Keine Ahnung.
Es sind andere Pornseiten, ja.
So, das ist der Unterschied dazwischen.
X Hamster.
Genau.
Also kann man, das ist ein guter
Vergleich.
Das ist wirklich
ziemlich gut, den Vergleich finde ich super.
Das kann man richtig
easy erklären.
Massive
Explosiver Fivehead hier.
Der ist schon
also der Vergleich ist wirklich gut.
Gleich gibt es den Bun. Warum?
Weil ich den Namen von
Seiten in den Mund genommen habe. Oh nein.
Cloud.
Okay, dann gucken wir Cloud noch schnell
bevor wir anfangen mit
GitHub Zeug. Was ist
Alter, was sieht denn die Seite aus? Sekunde,
das liegt am Darkreader, oder?
Okay, die Seite sieht auch so übelsetzlich
aus.
Okay, aber was hätte ich
von Oracle auch anders erwartet?
Am schlimmsten ist immer noch
IBM Help
Firmware
Downloadseite.
Fixed Central
kann das sein?
Die IBM Webseite
Docs
RSA2
oder so.
Die Seite ist schon so langsam.
Die geht gar nicht mehr auf.
Alter, diese IBM Seite,
wenn ich die sehe.
Ich meine, die ist schon
neuer als noch vor ein paar Jahren. Die haben hier
richtig was gemacht.
MSDN. Gibt es MSDN überhaupt
noch?
Ja gut, OpenBSD Org
ist ja das Paradebeispiel
für eine topaktuelle Web
5.0
NFT Crypto Blockchain AI
Webseite.
Die sind einfach komplett.
Also, so muss eine Webseite aussehen
heutzutage.
Aber eins muss man sagen,
die Seite, die hat quasi
nicht existente Ladezeiten.
Warum ist denn das Bild so groß?
Was haben die da für ein Bild
drauf gemacht, dass das
der Websober ist einfach lahm?
Das ist die beste
Seite. Ja, die ist top.
Die Webseite ist so
dermaßen schlecht.
Aber immerhin, Github
Mirror. Es gibt einen OpenBSD Github
Mirror. Okay.
Gönn dir mal die
ApiDocs Gelastic Api.
Das sieht doch eigentlich ganz okay aus.
So.
Also, jetzt mal zurück
zur eigentlichen
Geschichte. Also, Firefox
aufmachen.
Shithub öffnen.
Repoklonen. Ah, ich bin auch eingeloggt.
Exzellent.
Komm in den Starten.
Also, was wir heute machen, ist folgendes.
Ähm, ich
zeig euch mal.
Ach Mist, ich kann mich nicht
einloggen. Shit.
Ups. Äh, da muss ich
den Docker Container starten.
Ähm.
Docker PS?
Ah, was hatten wir da? Ach du Scheiße,
was hab ich denn da alles am Start?
QChat.
Äh.
Was war denn davon jetzt der richtige Container
created four days ago?
HungryEdison. Das klingt
gut. QChat. Wir starten QChat.
Alles klar.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das der richtige Container ist.
Ja, na, das sieht gut aus. Sieht gut aus. Das ist der richtige
Container. Äh, Exzeg.
Exzeg darauf.
Bash.
Jawoll. Sehr gut. Okay.
Root. Ich zeig euch
jetzt, was wir machen erst mal.
Was ist dieses QChat?
Das seid ihr.
Nicht
alle.
Aber die meisten.
So.
Teamaxe starten.
Start.
Soll ich zeige euch, was wir jetzt machen?
NPM run dev
ist es glaube ich. Okay.
Also was wir heute machen, ist folgendes.
Ja. Seite möge sich
bitte öffnen.
Genau. Also.
Das ist, wer das nicht kennt.
Das werde ich jetzt mal kurz zeigen. Das ist eigentlich ein ziemlich
nicees Projekt.
Ich kann euch, ich kann es euch nur
bei mir daheim zeigen. Leider nur das Dashboard,
weil ich das Login hier nicht habe.
Äh, Status Page.
Also hiermit überwache ich ein bisschen
Zeug bei mir daheim. Ob die, ob die Kisten
ab sind. Ob die Webseiten
funktionieren. Ob manche Ports offen sind.
So was. Und wenn es nicht ab ist,
dann sieht man das im Dashboard. Beziehungsweise
in der Detailansicht. So.
Das ist die einfachere
und sagen wir mal so.
Von der, von der, von
der Komplexität her. Die
sinnigere Variante für den Heimbetrieb
versus irgendwas wie
Zabbix, Nagios oder sonst was.
Kann man alles machen?
Ja. Von Check MK bis
Zabbix zu
Prometheus mit Krafana
obendrauf und sonst was. Kann man alles im Heimbereich
machen. Ist nicht verkehrt.
Ist alles in Ordnung. Aber das
schöne an Abzeichen Kuma ist der Name, der
macht mich immer noch ein bisschen fertig.
Funktioniert das auch über SNMP? Nein.
Die haben kein SNMP drinne.
Da musste dann Open
NMS oder irgendwas in der Richtung nehmen
oder Nagios oder Zabbix oder
was auch immer.
Oder Sentry oder Senzu
oder was es noch alles gibt.
Aber du kannst
also, du hast die Möglichkeit
wenn du SNMP verwenden willst
gibt es auch noch genau
hast du die Möglichkeit Push Notifications
zu machen. Also Push basiert ist.
Da müsst du halt auf irgendeiner Kiste
in den Skript laufen lassen, was SNMP abfragt
und dann dort Bescheid sagt. Aber dafür
ist es nicht wirklich gut geeignet.
Dazu bräuchte es die Möglichkeit noch vielleicht
Customs Scripts auszuführen. Aber die sind
da ziemlich, ziemlich krass am entwickeln.
Die haben fast täglich Merch
der Sachen, auch wenn es ein bisschen zurückgegangen ist,
weil er wohl gerade anderweitig beschäftigt ist.
Hier der Luis Lam.
Und
ich finde das Projekt auf jeden Fall richtig gut.
Hat auch viele Sterne auf GitHub.
Was mir noch ein bisschen fehlt
ist, ist das eine Linux VM auf die du
wechselst. Ja, ich habe
Windows, weil die Frage öfters kommt.
Ich habe Windows als Host und
Linux in einer VM hier. Guck da.
Nur, dass es im Fullscreen
läuft, deswegen fällt das kaum auf, dass es
eine VM ist.
So.
Ich zeige euch mal, wie einfach das
zu benutzen ist. Stellt euch mal vor,
ihr habt eine Webseite,
wo ihr checken wollt, ob die oben ist oder
nicht. Dann sagt ihr hier einfach,
wohlgemerkt, das ist jetzt ein bisschen
langsamer als normalerweise,
weil ich das Ganze im Development-Modus laufen
habe.
Werden dort Ports auf Verfügbarkeit
überprüft, aber wie funktioniert das?
Das kann ich dir jetzt zeigen.
Das ist ein bisschen sowas wie Uptime-Robot
und was es da nicht alles gibt. Also,
du gehst einfach auf Add Monitor und dann kannst du dir
überlegen, was du checken willst.
Du kannst HTTP checken. Du kannst
TCP-Ports überprüfen lassen.
Du kannst einfach nur pingen. Du kannst
HTTP überprüfen lassen
und gucken, ob irgendwelche
Wörter
in der Response drinne stehen, dass es
okay ist. Du kannst DNS-Auflösung
checken.
Du kannst...
PRTG gibt es auch. Das Problem an
PRTG ist, das höre ich immer wieder, dass
das eigentlich ganz gut sein soll,
PRTG ist Windows-Only und allein schon Windows-Only
ist für mich
Monka Shake,
Alter.
Tabx, Tabx habe ich ja gerade erzählt.
Also, es gibt ganz viel in der Richtung.
Du darfst
kein Linux nehmen
mit
irgendwie Gnome oder sonst was,
was gerne 3D-Beschleunigung
möchte oder zumindest Grafikkarten-Beschleunigung
in der Oberfläche. Du musst
irgendwas Minimalistisches nehmen.
Das am einfachsten zu bedienende Minimalistische
dürfte wahrscheinlich XFCE sein,
wobei das auch nicht so wahnsinnig gut
in VMs läuft. Mit I3 hast du halt keine
Probleme. I3 ist halt einfach
ohne Schnörkel, ja.
Zumindest kannst du als
Zumindest kannst du hier als
weiteren Monitoring-Check
noch einstellen. Push
und Push funktioniert über Webhook.
Da muss der Server, den du
überwachen willst, alle
60 Sekunden diese Url aufrufen.
Wenn er das nicht macht, geht der Check
automatisch daunen.
So, wir tragen
da jetzt einmal ein paar HTTPS-Checks ein,
weil ich heute was für Zertifikanten
einbauen will. Nehmen wir mal Google.
Also Google müssen wir unbedingt überprüfen.
Ganz wichtig, Google ist bestimmt daunen,
wenn wir das nicht machen.
Safe. Oh, Google ist ab.
Wer hätte das nur vermuten können?
So, dann legen wir
noch mehr HTTPS-Checks an. Zum Beispiel
können wir ein Wiki bei mir nehmen.
Mein lokales Wiki
können wir da mal eintragen.
Sehen wir auch.
Wiki.
Sehen wir auch. Wiki ist auch ab.
Wir brauchen ein paar zum
Testen. Dann hier Twitch.tv.
Twitch.
Überprüfen wir alle
60 Sekunden. Ist auch ab.
Hab eine Frage zu
I3.
Wie kann ich einen
Workspace duplizieren? Workspaces werden
immer zwischen Monitoren gesplittet.
Äh,
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher,
was du meinst.
Du meinst einen
Workspace, der über beide Monitore
gleichermaßen geht,
oder was?
Also hast du quasi einen Workspace,
hast über beide Monitore gleichzeitig.
Oder was?
Wie kannst du deine
Steckdosen darüber monitoren,
wenn die in einem abgeschottenen Wlan laufen?
Ja, das ist relativ easy.
Okay,
das muss ich euch jetzt einfach mal zeigen,
dass die Leute wissen, wovon ich rede.
Ich hab gestern ein Video gemacht.
Übrigens, wie findet ihr das Thumbnail?
Chat, wie findet ihr mal?
Ich zeige euch das mal,
ich zeige euch das mit dem Firefox,
aber Firefox spielt Videos nicht standardmäßig ab.
Gigachat Thumbnail.
Warum
spielt es automatisch ab?
Was ist los?
Ah hier, macht es doch nicht.
Gigachat Thumbnail.
Sack.
Ich muss die Musik ein bisschen leiser machen,
so.
Also Gigachat Thumbnail.
Home Server Enjoyer.
Ich finde das ist ein gutes Thumbnail.
Mal gucken, ob das Video noch Fahrt aufnimmt.
So, also um jetzt mal auf diese
Frage zurückzukommen.
Also, wie kannst du deine
Steckdose darüber monitoren, wenn die in einem abgeschottenen Wlan sind?
Worauf er sich bezieht ist,
muss man, blickt nicht mehr durch.
Übrigens, danke für die ganzen Subscriptions heute,
ich habe es voll verdrängt.
Ihr seid richtig Pock.
POG.
Hier ist nichts.
Ammo Falle,
so gehört sich das. Wolle auch am Start.
Noelle vor 5 Stunden.
Orgas.
So, weiter gehts.
So, worauf er
anspielt in dem Comment ist,
das Netzwerkdiagramm, was ich im Video gezeigt habe.
Ja, Max, halt die Klappe.
Worauf er anspielt,
ist das Netzwerkdiagramm, was ich im Video gezeigt habe.
So, und seine Frage ist
McFly, Dankeschön für den Sub übrigens, Leute.
Wenn auch any Primers am Start sind,
ich freue mich über jeden Prime Sub, hilft mir immer extrem.
Und wenn ihr
eher so der YouTube-Gucker seid,
weiß ich, ob euch das schon aufgefallen ist, ich habe mittlerweile sogar
Channel-Subscriptions auf YouTube aktiviert.
Da könnt ihr joinen
und könnt Kekse-Modes spammen auf
ganz YouTube.
Überall.
Solche Emotes könnt ihr dann da spammen.
Oder aber auf Twitch, da gibt es noch mehr.
ItzLuku,
Danke für den Sub.
So, also jetzt versuche ich das mal zu beantworten.
Ich habe dieses Diagramm hier gezeigt von meinem Netzwerk
und seine Frage ist jetzt, wie kann ich von dort
Geräte
hier drinnen überwachen?
Weil ich sage ja im Video, die Geräte hier
dürfen nirgends wohin.
Das ist auch so.
Mit dem Unterschied,
dass das Firewall technisch so
eingerichtet ist, diese Geräte hier
dürfen nicht raus.
Aber man darf ja von hier
da rein.
Das ist ja erlaubt.
Also wenn du hier eine Monitoring Software
drauf laufen lässt und machst
einen Ping auf eine Steckdose, die hier
drinne ist,
dann wird die Antwort dazu durchgelassen.
Weil das Establish Related ist.
Wenn man jetzt mal in
IP Tables
Termen spricht, ja.
In IP Tables ist das so, dass du
Connection Tracking
hast, also das ist in jeder Stateful Firewall
der letzten 30 Jahre so.
Dass du einstellst
das SYN-Paket
wenn das, wenn quasi
wenn das durch ist und alles was
zu dieser dann aufgebauten Verbindung gehört,
das ist erlaubt.
Also hier ist eingestellt, Verbindung
von hier
initiieren,
Verbindung von hier ist verboten.
Alter, warum ist die Musik so schlecht abgemischt, dass
das jetzt unterschiedlich laut ist?
Das Pains
Champ.
Okay. Genau.
Und das heißt,
wenn dieser Server hier irgendeine
Steckdose überwachen will, sei es Webseite
aufrufen oder anpingen, dann funktioniert
das. Der baut nämlich die Verbindung
auf von innen hier rein
und die Antwort ist dann erlaubt. Was
nicht erlaubt ist, ist die Verbindung von hier raus
irgendwo hin aufzubauen.
So.
Ich glaube, das hat man verstanden.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was du meinst. Also wenn du
wenn du
ein Workspace über
mehrere Monitore haben willst, dann musst du
mal gucken, da gibt es irgendeine
CineRama-Geschichte,
die man mit I3 machen kann.
Und
damit geht
das auf jeden Fall, weil dann I3
nur noch einen Bildschirm sieht für zwei.
Und alles andere habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Wenn ich mit I3 eine Präsentation mache und der
Beamer Workspace X anzeigt, dann habe ich den
Workspace nicht mehr auf meinem Laptop-Screen.
Ach, du willst den aus, du willst
den Output einfach klonen.
Du willst auf beiden exakt das gleiche haben.
Das musst du mit xrande machen,
und wenn du Kommandozeile hast, hier
xrande.
Habe ich nicht mal installiert.
Damit kannst du das machen. Das ist ein Kommandozeilen-Tool.
Warum habe ich das nicht installiert?
Echt nicht?
Ach so, ich muss
muss äh
muss das erst mal installieren.
Ja, damit kannst du das machen.
Das ist halt
normalerweise gedacht zum
zum Einstellen von
Auflösungen und Wiederholrate.
Aber damit kannst du auch so etwas machen wie
Duplicate Screen.
Ja, genau.
Da sagst du xrande Output
Same as Desktop zum Beispiel.
Ja, da kannst du auch noch mehr machen.
Du kannst skalieren und
einstellen, welcher Monitor
neben welchem Monitor ist, dass die Maus auf der
richtigen Seite rauskommt, wenn du das am Bildschirm ran machst.
Das ist aber ein bisschen Handarbeit.
Es gibt bestimmt
irgendwelche GUIs für x
xrande
aber die habe ich noch nicht verwendet.
Arande
Okay.
Zeig mal her. Arande
habe ich gerade gelernt. Okay.
Alter, das sieht aus wie
1995.
Dann lieber
ganz ehrlich, dann lieber Kommandozeile.
Da weiß man wenigstens
was passiert.
STBA 42.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Genau,
so war es da.
Was sagst du
zu WSL2
auf Windows
für alles mögliche?
Kann man machen.
Ganz ehrlich,
ich glaube mittlerweile
kannst du das meiste
mit WSL2 machen.
Ich habe trotzdem lieber eine VM
gerade für grafische Ausgaben.
Ich weiß, da gibt es mittlerweile auch Sachen.
Und weil ich gerne Arch Linux verwende
und einen eigenen Window Manager
drin habe, wie E3, spätestens das wird
ein bisschen schwierig mit WSL.
Wenn du
einfach nur Linux Tools verwenden willst,
ist WSL2 wahrscheinlich das beste, was du verwenden kannst.
So.
Gut.
Ich glaube, ich habe alles beantwortet.
Wir können jetzt mal anfangen.
Also Projekt habe ich gezeigt.
Also was wir heute
einbauen. Da habe ich auch schon im Vorfeld ein bisschen geguckt.
Ist wirklich einfach. Und da machen wir auch einen Pull Request auf.
Und in dem Pull Request könnt ihr
noch alle Daumen hoch geben,
dass der Maintainer das sieht und sich überlegt,
ob er es nicht vielleicht mercht, weil
das wäre glaube ich ein Feature, was echt allen was bringt.
Und zwar, wenn man hier mit
Webseiten überwacht, dann hat man hier die Anzeige
47 Tage
bis Zertifikat abläuft. Oder hier
128 Tage bis Zertifikat abläuft. Oder
35 Tage bis Zertifikat abläuft.
Man kann sogar, wenn man sagt,
man möchte sich benachrichtigen lassen, zum Beispiel
über Telegram oder Discord
oder so,
kann man sich sogar benachrichtigen lassen, wenn Zertifikate
auslaufen. Aber,
was ich gerne in der Übersicht hätte,
nämlich genau hier unten drunter,
also unterhalb dieser normalen
ähm,
sagen wir mal sowas, so hier, weil hier kommt gleich
ein Editor hin, was ich gerne
unterhalb dieser normalen Ansicht hätte,
ist eine kurze
Zertifikatsübersicht.
Quasi sowas hier,
nur halt mit maximal 5 Einträgen
oder so, dass es nicht so viel Platz wegnimmt.
Einfach, dass dann Zertifikate drunter stehen,
sortiert nach Ablaufdatum.
Dass man einfach auf einen Blick sieht,
ok, alles in Ordnung,
ich hab noch 14 Tage Zeit
oder sonst was. Einfach nur ein kurzer Überblick,
so sieht es mein Zertifikatstatus.
Das fehlt mir, das ist einer von zwei Sachen,
die mir fehlen, die ich wirklich gerne in der Software hätte,
deswegen basteln wir das mal selbst heute.
Auf geht's.
Socker Stels.
Schauen wir mal auf.
So, ich glaube, hier sind...
Oh, wir müssen die Changes vom letzten Mal
noch rückgängig machen, Leute, lull.
Repo, TMP.
Letzte Mal haben wir hier
komische Dinger gemacht.
Wir machen einfach Git, Reset,
Minus, Minus, Hard.
Übrigens, ich zeige euch mal einen coolen
Shit-Hack.
Komm mal, ich hab jetzt hier Sachen,
die ich jetzt in der Software
verwendet habe.
Git-Hack.
Komm mal, ich hab jetzt hier Sachen.
Sag mal, ich mach jetzt hier
Git, Commit, A
minus M
0W.
So, ich mach mal,
dass es einfacher ist.
Und ihr pusht das
nirgends wohin.
Ihr sagt einfach, ach komm, Scheiß drauf,
wir machen jetzt einfach Git,
Remote, Update und dann sagen wir
Git, Reset, Minus, Minus,
Hard,
Origin, Master.
So. Und jetzt
hab ich alle Änderungen weggeschmissen
und hab den Stand
hart auf das gesetzt, was gerade bei GitHub
Upstream aktuell ist.
Wenn euch jetzt einfällt,
Mist,
jetzt hab ich was gelöscht,
wo ich noch
nachgucken will
oder Mist, ich brauch das doch noch.
So einfach
kriegt ihr das nicht wieder. Aber
wenn ihr in dem Repo seid,
wo ihr diesen Change mal
gemacht habt, dann könnt ihr
Git Reflog verwenden.
Git Reflog ist quasi eine Historie
für jede Aktion, die euer
Git Repo ändert.
Von
neuestem bis ältestem.
Das heißt, das hier,
das Commit ist zwar
nicht mehr in der Historie drin,
aber anzeigen lassen kann ich's
immer noch.
Und ich kann sogar sagen,
Git Checkout,
also ich hab als
Shortcut nicht, dass ihr euch wundert, Git CO,
das ist bei mir Checkout, aber ich schreib das mal aus.
Checkout da drauf machen
und ihr den ganzen Cremple angucken.
Oh, sagste, aha, aha,
das hier hab ich gemacht. Exquisite,
exquisite, alles bestens, ja, das brauch ich wieder.
Und wenn ihr euch das angehört und sagt, ah,
ich brauch das doch, dann könnt ihr sogar
von diesem temporären Stand
wieder
einen Tempbrunch aufmachen
und dann habt ihr's wieder. Guck, hier habt ihr jetzt
die Historie mit dem Kram
und wenn ihr auf
Master checkoutet, habt ihr den anderen Kram.
Also das ist nice.
Warum findest du das gruselig?
Das ist doch gut, wenn du Sachen, die du
aus Versehen gelöscht hast, wieder herstellen kannst.
Ach ja, was das, was nicht
geht, ist, solltet ihr euer Git
Repo löschen, ist es weg.
Also,
solltet ihr euer Git, solltet ihr m-rf.git
machen und quasi diese interne
Dateistruktur von Git löschen, ist weg.
Das geht nur in dem Repo,
wo ihr dieses Comet mal gemacht habt.
Aber das ist gut, dass wir das gesetzt haben,
weil das machen wir heute eh nicht.
Also Ziel heute ist,
ich geh mal kurz da rein, Code,
Bäm.
Ziel heute ist, und dass wir das zeitlich auch hinkriegen,
ich hab im Vorfeld schon ein bisschen geguckt, wie wir's machen.
Nein, ich will nicht die
Extensions installieren und
mein original Studio Code,
gib doch einfach Ruhe.
Gib doch einfach Ruhe.
Ich brauch jetzt keine Arduino Zeug.
So. Ja.
Installieren.
Ich glaub,
den Kram mach ich alles mal zu.
Reload.
Jawoll.
So, wunderbar.
Also, was ich haben will ist,
hier oben drüber eine Übersicht über alle meine
Ablaufen und Zertifikate.
Und ich hab im Vorfeld schon mal
geguckt, dazu müssten wir in
Dashboard Home, mach das hier mal
alles zu, dass man ein bisschen besser
was sieht. Wir müssen das hier mal
ein bisschen kleiner.
Nicht ganz so klein.
Hier drunter will ich jetzt eine Übersicht haben,
für meine ablaufenden Zertifikate.
Und wir müssen erst mal gucken,
wo wir das Ganze hinpappen.
Hier, Test, Test, Test.
Jawoll. Nein, hier will ich es nicht hin haben.
Ich will das wahrscheinlich
hier hin haben.
Ja, genau.
Also, QuickStats, dass mir oben die
Übersicht hat zwischen Services,
Up, Down und da unten drunter
eine kurze Übersicht über Zertifikate.
Das fände
ich persönlich nice.
Mal gucken, ob das dem Maintainer gefällt.
Da bin ich mir nicht so sicher. Keine Ahnung.
Aber wir machen mal die Änderung.
Das wird nicht viel. Das sind am Ende vielleicht
40, 50 Zeilen inklusive HTML.
Und JavaScript.
Und dann machen wir mal einen Pull-Request auf.
Da kann ich euch auch mal zeigen, wie das funktioniert.
Und dann gucken wir
mal, ob er das
nimmt. Ihr dürft das natürlich dann
liken.
Vielleicht macht sich das
dann gut oder so. Keine Ahnung.
Schauen wir mal. Also wir müssen jetzt
hier irgendwie rein bekommen. Zertifikats
Übersicht. So.
Und
was ich cool finde,
was an diesem Softwareprojekt,
was der gemacht hat, ist, das muss er
aber auch machen. Deswegen mag ich
auch Projekte,
die aus asiatischen
Ländern kommen. Die haben
standardmäßig meistens Übersetzungs-,
also Translation-Support.
Weil die genau wissen,
international wird den
Kram keiner verwenden oder kann
niemand verwenden, wenn das in Chinesisch ist
oder in Japanisch oder in Koreanisch.
Das heißt, die meisten, zumindest die Leute,
die da drauf achten, der asiatischen
Projekte, haben die Möglichkeit,
die Sachen zu Translaten.
Das heißt, am besten wäre
für uns, dass wir das so, dass wir
uns Texte aus der Übersetzung-,
ja,
wie nennt man das,
Übersetzungstabelle da raussuchen,
die es schon gibt,
dass wir gar nichts zusätzliches hinzufügen
müssen. So, und da habe
ich im Vorfeld schon mal geguckt.
Es gibt da nämlich zum Beispiel schon drin,
ich mache mal die deutsche Datei auf und ich mache mal
die englische Datei auf, es gibt da
zum Beispiel Certificate Info.
Und das wäre für uns eine super
Überschrift.
In Deutsch heißt das Ganze
übrigens
Certificate Info.
Das heißt, wenn wir das hier verwenden
mit dem Übersetzungssupport,
sobald man die Sprache umstellt,
stimmt der Text automatisch.
Und das ist cool. Und
wenn Software das hat,
finde ich es ganz praktisch, dass man die Sachen
verwendet, die schon drin sind,
dann muss man nämlich nicht für
keine Ahnung
20 Sprachen
das neue, neuen Text
übersetzen.
So, also wir wollen als Überschrift haben,
ne, wir
kopieren, wir kopieren uns
einfach mal, wir sind jetzt richtig,
wir crappen uns jetzt
die Tabelle, die er hier unten gemacht hat,
copypasten die
und passen die an. So, guck, jetzt haben wir die
Tabelle hier doppelt drin.
Das will man natürlich so nicht haben.
Und ich lösche
diesen ganzen Krempel mal bis
auf die,
ja,
eigentlich bis auf alles. Lul, das hat sich jetzt aber voll
gelohnt, das zu kopieren.
Moment,
das ist ja auch falsch.
Ich will
Padding haben unten.
So. Und ich will
die Überschrift haben. Überschrift
ist das da.
Das muss ich mir eigentlich kopieren.
Ich will ja das da oben,
das da oben faken.
So, jetzt
haben wir das einmal kopiert.
Und wir wollen dann
eine Überschrift haben. So, Überschrift
ist, was habe ich
gesagt, was brauchen wir?
Certificate Info.
Wenn man schon Translation Support einbaut
dann für alle Sprachen. Ja, ich finde das wirklich
bei asiatischen Projekten echt nice.
Also ich habe das schon bei einigen asiatischen Projekten gesehen,
dass die eben Translation Support drin haben.
Ganz ehrlich, wenn es nach
mir geht, ich bräuchte es natürlich nicht, wenn einfach jeder
alles in Englisch macht. Aber
es gibt genug Leute, die eben ihre Native Sprache
verwenden wollen in der Software. Und gerade
muss man ja auch mal sagen, das ist ja
auch eine Software für Leute, die sich jetzt, also das
ist ja eine Software, die sich an Leute richtet, die
jetzt vielleicht nicht so krass technisch versiert sind
und daheim zwei Raspberry Pies laufen haben
mit drei Services und benachrichtigt
werden wollen, wenn es kaputt geht.
Und dafür ist schon
sinnvoll. Guck mal, ich kann euch sogar zeigen,
dass es funktioniert. Ich kann hier auf Settings gehen
und dann stellt
man ein, wo stellt man überhaupt die Sprache
ein? Appearance, Englisch.
So, Deutsch
und schon haben wir die Übersicht
und alles hier auf Deutsch. Also
Translation Support ist wirklich
eine nice
Geschichte.
Englisch.
Und seht ihr, wie das On-the-Fly geht?
Das geht auch noch, weil es eine View-Kleinzeit-Application
ist, ohne Seiten-Reload.
Also, gucken wir mal.
Wie kriegen wir das denn jetzt
gebacken?
Schmeißen wir das hier mal kurz raus.
Certificate
Info wollen wir da oben drüber
schreiben. Also.
Da brauchen wir nicht mal, da brauchen wir schon mal
nicht Pause, sondern wir brauchen
Certificate
Info als Text.
So, funktioniert auch.
So, wie mach ich da jetzt eine hübsche Überschrift?
Gerade der Minimalismus macht für mich
Kummer als Admin echt interessant.
Ja,
wobei mich da mal interessieren wird, wie gut die Performance
ist mit vielen Kisten drin.
Also, ich hab
es mir nur ganz kurz angeguckt. Das ist
halt ein Node.js Express
Backend. Ich bin mir nicht sicher,
wie gut die Checks parallelisiert sind
beziehungsweise
wie gut das entkoppelt ist.
Keine Ahnung. Also, ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass das mal mit 100 plus Checks
anfängt so langsam, aber sicher
in die Knie zu gehen. Nein, wir
Translateen nicht, wir basteln eine Zertifikatsübersicht.
Was ich halt cool finde, dass du da noch ein Dashboard
hast. Du kannst halt dieses Dashboard
das Dashboard kann man hosten
sagen wir Public Hosten
halt freischalten.
Da kann man das seinen Kunden zeigen, wenn die
gucken wollen, wie die Uptime ist und ob es gerade
Probleme gibt. Und das hat man halt
intern. Da ist die Moab.
Danke schön für den Sub.
Richtig nice Moab.
So, also ich muss jetzt mich mal kurz
ein bisschen konzentrieren.
Also Zertifikatsinfo
soll da oben drin stehen und zwar
hübsch. Dann schreiben wir das doch einfach mal
da rein.
Da ist es nämlich schon...
Monkeys, was jetzt? Ah,
ich muss die Klammern wegmachen. Cool.
So, Zertifikatsinfo in
Fett. Das ist doch schon mal nice.
So, Text,
Center,
ist das in der Mitte. Schaut mal
exellent aus.
So, Zertifikatsinfo und
da drunter brauchen wir jetzt
das ist glaube ich
Bootstrap, was der verwendet. Leute sagen einem
die Klassen was ist das?
Bootstrap, was da unten drunter verwendet
oder hat er das selbst gemacht?
Da jemand
versiert drin.
Nee, nach Tailwind sieht es nicht
aus.
Ja, BS.
Steht im Report drin?
Ist das Bootstrap? Ja.
Schau the power of
Bootstrap 5.
Ah, huge power. Massive
Power, Alter. So, also
ich hab mir gedacht wir machen das jetzt folgendermaßen.
Anstatt Up, Down, Down anzuzeigen,
zeigen wir an.
Ähm,
Zertifikate,
alles in Ordnung.
Zertifikate laufen in den nächsten 7 Tagen ab
und Zertifikaten laufen,
läuft innerhalb des nächsten Tages ab oder sind schon
abgelaufen.
Das bedeutet wir brauchen hier unten drunter
noch mal eine Row.
Row.
Und da kopieren wir den Krempel rein. Wir brauchen 3 Stück.
Wir brauchen 3 Stück.
Äh, was hab ich jetzt falsch gemacht?
Warum ist das jetzt nebeneinander und nicht
untereinander?
Muss ich ja vielleicht Calum
dran schreiben oder so?
Weil hier ist überall eine Calum drum herum.
Aha!
Aha! Okay,
Porras.
Ich hab keine Ahnung
von Bootstrap, Alter.
So,
Stats Up.
Dann wollen wir hier haben Text
Danger. Klingt gut.
Text Danger.
Das ist für Zertifikate, die abgelaufen sind
oder innerhalb von einem Tag ablaufen.
Text Secondary.
Was ist das für ne Farbe?
Ah.
Äh,
Danger?
Gibt es Warning oder sowas?
Ah ja,
das will ich haben. Text Warning.
Das ist für Zertifikate, die innerhalb von 7 Tagen
bald auslaufen.
Und Grün ist alles
in Ordnung.
Das finde ich eigentlich schon mal gut. Kann man keine Ahnung sagen.
12 Zertifikate sind okay.
3 laufen demnächst ab und
1 ist abgelaufen. So würde es dann oben aussehen.
Gibt es einen TLDR?
Äh, ja,
TLDR, also,
ich weiß nicht, ob du das Projekt kennst.
Das ist so Monitoring Light für den Heimbereich.
Deutlich einfacher als irgendwie Nagios,
Zappix oder sonst was. Kannst du auch alles über
Webinterface konfigurieren.
Und was ich gerne hätte ist, also du kannst
Checks hinzufügen, die überprüfen,
ob Webseiten erreichbar sind und auch
ob Zertifikate gültig sind. Was mir
fehlt ist
eine Zertifikatsübersicht.
Du kannst dich zwar
Notification schicken lassen,
wo dann drinne steht, Achtung, ihr Zertifikat ist abgelaufen.
Aber vielleicht will man ja nicht unbedingt eine Notification
haben, sondern einfach mal auf einen
Blick eine kurze Übersicht.
Wie sieht es aus? Zertifikate gültig,
Zertifikate abgelaufen, Zertifikate laufen
bald ab. Im Webinterface.
Und so was bauen wir jetzt.
Das sieht dann im Prinzip ein bisschen aus wie hier plus für Zertifikate.
So stelle ich mir das vor, dass
dann drinne steht 12 Zertifikate, alles
in Ordnung, drei Stück laufen
innerhalb von sieben Tagen ab und eins ist schon abgelaufen.
So.
Ablaufende
Zerts tauchen auch im Log unten auf.
Ähm.
Nee.
Doch.
Ja und nein. Es taucht
im Log auf.
Wenn.
Das müssen wir mal
überprüfen.
Das müssen wir mal überprüfen.
Das müssen wir jetzt mal checken.
Also es steht auf jeden Fall im Log unten drinne,
wenn das Zertifikat nicht mehr
gültig ist. Ich bin mir aber nicht sicher,
ob im Log unten drinne steht,
ob das Zertifikat demnächst abläuft.
Hat mal jemand eine Seite,
wo das Zertifikat den nächsten Tage über abläuft?
Das müssen wir prüfen ist auch ein richtig schöner Business Satz.
Ja, das stimmt.
Bad, Zert,
Expire Soon.
Gibt's da, hat da irgendwie einer was?
Also Bad, Bad SSL
hat glaub ich keinen für
Expired bald.
Also die Playlist
ist wirklich mega schlecht abgemischt.
Mal ist es laut, mal ist es leise.
Ne, Bad SSL
hat nichts,
mit Zertifikat läuft bald ab.
Bad SSL
hat Zertifikat läuft ab
oder ist abgelaufen.
Das kann ich euch zeigen, das funktioniert.
Hier Bad.
Da kannst du hier sagen Save
und Bäm, geht nicht, weil Zertifikat
has expired.
Das siehst du hier unten, aber hier unten
stehen halt zwei Zertifikat.
stehen halt alle anderen Monitoring Meldungen auch drinne.
Banggood
war gestern abgelaufen, wirklich?
Ich brauche nichts, was gestern
abgelaufen war, sondern
ich brauche eine Seite
Was für ein Ding soll ich nehmen?
Traberinfo
Coming Soon
Okay, weiß nicht was das ist, aber
ach das war es von dir, okay
passt, dann nehmen wir das.
Zack
Expire Test
In 19 Tagen
Ich weiß halt nicht ab wann das theoretisch
warnen würde.
Ich würde halt erwarten, dass das warnt
unter 7 Tage.
Und ich vermute mal,
das macht einfach gar nichts.
Das leitet doch weiter automatisch.
Ach guck mal Banggood ist abgelaufen.
Lull
Am 24. schon, die Chinesen
Alter
Die China-Chinesen
die interessieren das nicht ob ihre Zertifikate
ausgelaufen sind oder nicht.
Okay, das müssen wir auf jeden Fall
überprüfen, bevor wir dann Pull-Request
aufmachen, weil ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass es vielen schon reicht, wenn es einfach
hier unten drin steht, läuft bald aus.
Du hast eine, gut,
dann ist das so, wie ich mir das vorstelle.
Du bekommst eine Notification,
aber es wird nicht angezeigt
explizit im Web-Interface, dass es ausläuft.
Also du hast keine Übersicht so nach dem
Motto, Zertifikate laufen bald aus,
Zertifikat ist ausgelaufen und
alles in Ordnung.
Wir bauen das einfach mal.
Also mir fehlt so eine
Übersicht, weil ich ganz gerne einen Überblick habe.
Was weiß ich, ist noch 90 Tage,
ist noch 40 Tage gültig oder so.
Dann sehe ich nämlich auch, okay,
es müsste sich ab 30 Tagen eigentlich erneuern,
hat es aber nicht, ist noch alles in Ordnung,
aber ich wüsste es gerne.
Okay, gucken wir mal, wir bauen das jetzt
einfach ein.
Und was ist, wenn du
deine Systemuhr umstellst?
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Da reagieren
manche Zertifikate empfindlich,
also SSL Geschichten empfindlich drauf.
Das mit Systemuhr
können wir tatsächlich ausprobieren.
Ich muss euch aber gestehen, ich habe absolut keine Ahnung,
wie ich in
Docker die Systemzeit umstelle.
Checkt das, wenn ich
meine
Systemzeit an sich umstelle.
Date?
Du kannst ja mappen.
Es reicht ja, wenn ich
Docker Change Time
Inside Container.
Müssen wir mal nachgucken.
Five Ways to Change Time.
Ich will nicht die Time Zone
changen, ich will
die Zeit changen.
Na gut, ich meine, ich kann einfach sagen,
Date, was ist das, Date minus S?
Alter, das Format
von Date minus S kann ich mir doch mal bestmöglich
erklären. 30.01.
Invalid Date.
Ist das, ist das
Kokona? Ist das Kokona Date?
Nee, Date Set
Time, das kann ich mir immer nicht merken.
Date minus
S.
Okay, alles klar.
Not permitted
RIP.
Aber wenn ich das aufm, was ist, wenn ich das aufm
House Change?
Ha, guck mal, wie es überschreibt.
Lul, irgendwo ist NTP
am Start.
Oder ATC
Local Time Mappen ist am
einfachsten. Da muss ich den Container
aber neu erstellen, ne?
Kann ich mal ein Home Assistant testen? Ja, Home Assistant
ist richtig, richtig pock. Würde, würde
das Home Assistant übernehmen, wenn ich das hier?
Alter, mein NTP ist zu schnell.
Wo kommt denn das her?
System CTL
Boah, woher, woher bekomme ich mein NTP?
Nee, wie heißt das?
Time, Time, Time CTL
oder so?
Time Date CTL
NTP Service Active, NTP
Set
Set NTP
Null, war das so?
Okay, inactive, alles klar.
Date
Okay, es wird nicht mehr überschrieben.
Date, haha
Leute, passt, funktioniert.
So, also, wir haben
nicht Oktober, wir haben Januar
Alter,
wir haben Januar 2000
und zwar haben wir da jetzt
den 15.
18 Uhr, sehr gut.
Date
Refresh
Ich bin nicht sicher, ob das
jetzt neu eingelesen hat.
Hat das neu eingelesen?
Nee
Das hat nicht neu eingelesen.
Ich glaube, da muss ich das neu starten.
Der läuft im Container.
Wahrscheinlich muss ich
neu starten, dass er das einliest.
What?
Was?
Sag bloß, meine
VM hat Zeit gesetzt, Alter.
Ähm
Stellt man das
überhaupt ein Advanced?
Kann man
den Uhrzeit-Sync irgendwie ausschalten?
Vor allem bei Tools. Time Sync off.
Nee
Okay, dann weiß ich nicht, wo es herkommt.
No
Nee, wobei, ist doch richtig.
Ist doch alles richtig.
15. Januar
Def
Okay, laden wir mal neu und gucken, wie da jetzt
die Zeit aussieht.
In 24 Tagen, das sieht
besser aus.
In 8 Tagen.
Nee, man bekommt keine
Expire-Meldung.
Nee.
Ähm, wir sind jetzt mal ganz
frech, wir stellen das jetzt wirklich
hoch.
Okay, das habe ich tatsächlich doppelt laufen jetzt.
Ähm, wir
stellen das jetzt mal date.
Wir setzen es jetzt mal auf 21. Also spätestens
dann sollte es eigentlich eine Meldung geben,
dass es abläuft oder nicht.
Run
So.
Nee, es gibt, es gibt keine Meldung, ob das
expired oder nicht. Guck, das
expired. Das expired in 2
Tagen. Es ist immer noch ab
und es gibt keine Meldung. Achtung, Zertifikat
expired.
Doch da? Wo?
Wo?
Hä?
Hier ist keine Meldung, dass es expired?
Ja Moment, es geht nicht darum,
dass du eine Meldung bekommst, Zertifikat hat
expired. Es geht mir darum, ob
das im Vorfeld irgendwas anzeigt.
So, Achtung, es läuft ab
in 7, 6, 5,
4, 3, 2, 1, bumm.
Das gibt es nicht.
Was du bekommst, ist eine Notification.
Wenn du Notifications eingerichtet hast, dann
bekommst du was. Okay,
dann ist es doch sinnvoll und dann fehlt
mir die Übersicht tatsächlich.
Weil ich hätte gerne so eine Übersicht so nach dem
Motto, okay, ist noch in Ordnung, läuft
erst ab, aber halt in 3 Tagen. So
von eher auf einen Blick. Möglichst kurz,
dass es nur so viel vom Bildschirm
in Anspruch nimmt.
Schauen wir mal.
Also, erst nochmal stoppen.
NTP,
auf eins setzen. Ey, die Musik
in dieser Kirby-Playlist ist wirklich schlecht
abgemischt.
Das ist mal laut, das ist mal leise.
Nee, den Mario Kart Soundtrack
machen wir jetzt nicht.
Wir machen jetzt, habe ich nicht hier
noch ein bisschen Mario Kart offen?
Hier.
Wow.
Jawoll.
Excellent.
Pepe, please.
Monkastier. So, ist
Daytime wieder richtig? Jawoll, Zeit
ist jetzt 4. Januar, wunderbar.
Gut, da können wir anfangen. Wir haben überprüft, dass es doch
sinnvoll ist, weil ich da gebastelt habe.
Geh aus.
Gut, können wir also
weitermachen mit der eigentlichen Geschichte, was ich vor hatte.
Feature im Log
ergänzen, ansonsten weißt du ja nicht, welches
Zertifikat abläuft.
Nee, da kommt jetzt
noch so eine Tabelle drunter.
Sortiert nach Ablaufdatum.
So, wie machen wir da so eine Tabelle?
Tabelle.
Also das finde ich als, das finde ich
oben drüber als Übersicht
schon mal ganz gut.
Ich spiele den
Track. Wie, du spielst gerade
Mario Kart?
Gelbe Meldungen im Log.
Das ist nicht so einfach.
Da müsste ich den HTTP Check
den HTTP
Check anpassen.
Das muss ich mir mal überlegen.
Da weiß ich nicht, wie es funktioniert.
Da müsste ich den HTTP Check irgendwie anpassen.
Zumal es eigentlich nur
Up und Down als Status gibt.
Es gibt gar nicht sowas.
Also dann müsste ich sagen, Status ist
Up, aber dann müsste ich
irgendwie noch Zusatzinformation
bei der Anzeige.
Ja doch, das könnte man machen.
Das könnte man machen.
Das müsste man dann hier in
Das müsste man
dann hier anzeigen.
Hier in der Tabelle müsste man
das dann machen. Guckt mal.
Dort, wo der jetzt
diese Records rendert.
Nämlich hier.
Guckt da.
Das müsste ich dann gelb machen.
Also Status müsste ich dann quasi
gelb machen.
Das geht nicht. Das ist der extra Component.
Das machen wir mal kurz
hier.
Gelbes
Log
wenn
Frage.
Das committe ich nicht, weil ich mach bestimmt keine
deutschen Comments da
rein.
Was nutzt du
für die Live-Preview über
das? Gar nichts.
Das ist ein
Veed Projekt.
Das macht das automatisch.
Wenn du die Dateien änderst, dann macht das
Reload.
So. Okay, jetzt bauen wir erstmal meine Tabelle,
wie ich das ursprünglich vorhabe. Also wir hatten eine
Übersichtzertifikate. Wie wir die Daten reinkriegen,
muss ich dann gleich nochmal gucken, aber ich habe
mir das im Vorfeld auch schon angeguckt. Heute ist ein bisschen
mit Vorbereitung.
Meinst du,
sowas gibt es für
Express, GS?
Das Backend davon ist Express.
Also wir brauchen eine Tabelle.
Table
Gucken wir mal, wo muss die denn hin?
Da? Muss die Tabelle
dahin? Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Table.
Lull. Sieht es
tabelig aus.
Table head.
Ich
meine, wenn man Express, GS mit einem, oh boah,
ich habe keine Ahnung von JavaScript.
Auch wenn das heute vielleicht so wirkt, als
wüsste ich, was ich mache, aber eigentlich weiß ich das
nicht. Ach guck mal,
das ist tatsächlich, es funktioniert mit der Tabelle.
Also wir brauchen keine,
also was brauchen wir
da überhaupt jetzt als Anzeige
für die Zertifikate, die auslaufen.
Also Name ist auf jeden Fall
schon mal gut.
Status
ist wahrscheinlich
auch nicht so schlecht.
Und Date, Time ist auch
nicht schlecht.
Das lassen wir erstmal so.
Wir könnten allerdings mal gucken in der Übersetzung,
weil ich bilde mir ein, ich habe irgendwas
gesehen von CertExp.
Dass wir
das nehmen anstatt
ähm
anstatt Status.
So.
So war es. Und was
ich auch noch gesehen habe, es gibt Days
und da könnten wir theoretisch
sowas machen. CertExp
und in Klammern
und in Klammern,
wie macht man das dann eigentlich so hier? Klammern
und in Klammern dann
Days.
So und wenn wir das jetzt richtig
gemacht haben,
wenn wir das jetzt richtig gemacht
haben und umstellen auf Deutsch,
dann sollte da stehen
sowas sinngemäß wie
in Days Left gibt es leider
eine Übersetzung im Übersetzungsfeil nicht.
Sollte da sowas stehen wie
Zertifikat, Ablauf,
Tage.
Schauen wir mal, ob das da
drinnen steht.
Wo war es nochmal?
Appearance, ach hier
Englisch. So, Deutsch.
Zertifikat, Ablauf, Tage.
Das ist doch in Ordnung. Das
kann man sich doch geben.
Einstellungen.
Bisschen laut, oder? Wieder schlecht
abgemischte Playlist.
Du du du du.
Ja.
Yoshi Valley, beste.
So, Englisch.
Gut, das finde ich nice.
Das gefällt mir.
Ich hätte noch eine Idee, was wir anzeigen.
Wir zeigen noch
Issuer an.
Also der
der
der das
ausgestellt hat.
Das fände ich noch eine gute Idee.
Da sieht man nämlich gleich um welche Zertifikats geht.
Issuer.
Das übersetzen wir nicht, weil das heißt
halt einfach so. Da steht ein Zertifikat
so drinnen. Das würde ich auch in allen
Sprachen dann so reinschreiben.
Das ist derjenige, der das Zertifikat ausgestellt hat.
Da steht dann sowas wie Let's Encrypt zum Beispiel
drinne und sowas.
So.
Und wie möchten wir, dass da so ein Eintrag
aussieht?
Wie macht man jetzt die Tabelle weiter?
T-Body.
Ich bin so HTML und JavaScript
Noob.
T4. Okay, das ist jetzt
die eigentliche
Tabelle. Moment.
Wie baut man so eine
Tabelle auf? TR.
Geben wir das dann direkt rein und dann nochmal
TR.
Ach, das ist Table Row.
Und was ist Table Cell?
Oder sowas.
Och Gott. Warte mal.
Sieht man doch. Das steht doch hier unten.
TD. TD.
Ah. Yes.
HTML Experte am Start.
Alles klar.
So will ich das haben. Das ist doch schick.
Das ist doch schick.
So. Da steht dann drinne
zum Beispiel Wiki.
Wiki.
Verlinkt. Verlinkt auf die
jeweilige Seite. Das wenn ich da drauf drücke,
dass ich dann rauskomme. Eventuell
noch über die Zahl
Überschriften wie abgelaufen. Da haben wir doch.
Name. Third Expire Days.
Daytime Issue.
So. Da steht dann
sowas drinne wie
24 oder so.
Tage.
Date Time.
Da steht dann sowas drinne wie 22
der 10.
2022 oder so.
Hatten
der nicht eine Date Time Component?
Doch hatte er. Hier. Guckt mal.
Date Time.
Das brauchen wir.
Date Time Value.
Ach so. New
Date. Brauchen wir da wahrscheinlich.
Ja. So wollen wir das da nicht anzeigen.
Gekürzte Variante gab es doch
auch. Ich glaube war Short.
Short?
Oh.
Ne.
Äh.
Table Bestes Layout.
Ja. Poggers.
Muss mal kurz
bei mir was spicken.
Bin mir nämlich nicht mehr ganz sicher.
Nein. Date Only musste man reinschreiben.
Siehste?
Date. Only.
Jetzt ist das nämlich
kürzer. So. So würde dann ein Eintrag
hier aussehen. Und ich würde
am liebsten hier noch so eine
Farbe drum herum machen. Also quasi
ähm.
Machen wir das mal. Machen wir das mal auf die nächste
Seite.
So. Und das wir
dann da was rein machen wie
Diff.
Class.
Und das wir das
irgendwie Highlighten.
So. Keine Ahnung. Style.
Gleich. Äh.
BG oder Background Color.
Background Orange.
Boah.
Igitt. Alter das sieht hässlich aus.
Ihr weiß nicht ob so eine gute
Idee ist.
Ähm. Ja.
Aber Classes. Classes muss
ich mir noch mal abgucken hier.
Genau. Ich RIP mir
das einfach von hier unten wie der das gemacht hat.
Ne. Einfach von Status
übernehmen kann ich nicht.
Doch. Wobei wir können uns das aus der
Status Component angucken.
Status. Hier.
Color. Danger.
Wie jetzt?
Hä? Ach hier.
BG Color Text.
Rounded
Pill.
Bettge. Leute. Bettge.
Endlich ist es offiziell.
Auch in Bootstrap.
Bettge.
Wobei das nicht
guter aussieht.
Ja so ist besser.
Man kann in der Status Component schon
die Background Farbe.
Äh.
Nicht wirklich.
Ach.
Ach doch.
Ok. Das probieren wir
mal aus.
Mal gucken wie das aussieht.
Status.
Status. Null.
Da steht aber
Down und Up und so. Das ist bei
Zertifikaten
eigentlich doof weil das
ist nicht das was man haben will.
Wie viele Zertifikate soll angezeigt
werden? Äh. Ich würde sagen
5. Und nach 5
gibt es dann. Ja sieht man hier jetzt nicht.
Nach 5 würde ich dann umschalten
mit so einer Leiste unten.
Also
Pending ist ziemlich doof für Zertifikate.
Ich meine
Pending geht noch irgendwo.
Pending so nach dem Motto es
pendet zu expiren.
Aber. Aber Up
und Down ist schon irgendwie eine
doofe Anzeige für Zertifikate oder?
Guck mal wir haben sind das
wir haben sind das.
Der Graf leute.
Wisst ihr warum das so aussieht weil ich die Uhrzeit auf
2006 zurückgestellt habe
und dann vorgestellt habe und so.
Excellent
Graf. So
sieht Zeitreise Stocks
aus hier.
Valid. Das hier meine
ich. Das hier meine ich. So.
Hier hat er nämlich sowas schon.
Das rippen wir uns einfach von der
von der anderen Seite und zwar
müssen wir hier auf
Details ist das.
Details
waren Details unter Pages
TLS Info
TLS
Info
Ah ne Zertifikate Info ist eine
eigene OK
Zertifikate
Info
hier guck mal
D Inline Flex MS2 Text White Tag Invalid
Alles klar
Das wollen wir haben.
Das kann zu
Das kann auch zu
Dashboards kann auch zu
Also wir wollen wir wollen haben
Ja
Das sieht schon mal ganz gut aus
Tag Invalid
Gibt es das ist das vielleicht lokal hier
Ach ja guck mal hier
Tag Valid Tag
Invalid
Ok. Exzellent. Exzellent.
Copy Paste wir uns das mal hier rein
Zack. Jawoll. Das sieht gut aus.
So gefällt mir das
Also das da hinten
mit dem Issuer gefällt mir nicht aber
das Issuer würde dann so was drin
stehen wie Let's Encrypt
oder so
Leute was findet ihr
besser oder ich glaube ich
glaube ich weiß es schon
ich glaube es ist
besser wir machen die Tage
wir machen die Tage
ein
Kreis drum
Ach ja warum ich das nicht automatisch formatieren
lasse ist weil ich keinen Bock habe
mit dem Switchless Studio das halbe Projekt
umformatiert
Ja guck mal
das finde ich nice
das finde ich sehr hübsch so mag ich das
warum der Preis
Champdown ist weil ich den abgeschaltet habe
guck mal so
so wäre doch nice so
und dann gibt es da noch andere Zertifikate da drin
so dann gibt es dann zum Beispiel
noch hier keine Ahnung
Home Assistant oder so
oder was auch immer ist auch egal
so und das läuft ab in 11
Tagen und ist dann quasi
Batch Valid
so aber wir brauchen noch
wir brauchen noch eine wir brauchen noch eine
CSS für Orange
wir machen
wir nennen das anders
wir machen das anders
es ist Tag
es ist Tag okay
Danger
und es ist
Tag
Warning
oder Warn Warn
komm ich nenne es Error Scheiß drauf
kann ich mir besser was darunter vorstellen
so
Rot ab Minus
2 ja das finde ich ist eine gute Idee
die Playlist ist auch wieder mega kacke abgemischt
guck mal jetzt es wird richtig laut und das andere nicht
so
also und jetzt würde ich sagen wir machen das
einfach an der Stelle
mal zum Vergleich
ich muss es ein bisschen kleiner machen
sonst sehe ich nichts
wir können auch das als Schrift im Editor ein bisschen kleiner machen
so Tag
okay
Tag Warn
ne
Tag Error
und dann machen wir noch einen
gucken wir uns jetzt noch mal einen an
mit Gelb
was weiß ich das sind dann irgendwie
ab unter 7 Tagen
oder so ist dann Warning
ich will nichts formatieren
und save
ne ne ne das ist Absicht deswegen habe ich das so abgestellt
ich hab das extra abgeschaltet
dass ich dann nicht Zeugs umformatiere
wo ich nichts drin zu suchen habe
so
so würde das dann da drin stehen
das ist doch eigentlich ganz nice oder
jetzt müssen wir das nur noch
dynamisch bauen also nur noch
nur noch dynamisch bauen
also wir hatten irgendeine Question im Chat
gerade einer meiner Chatplains flieht
ich bin mal gespannt ich kann mir nicht vorstellen
dass das Frontend technisch
Visual Studio Code ablöst
Visual Studio Code ist halt in Javascript
für Javascript Hacker Mans
aber wofür
ich mir ganz gut vorstellen kann sind so Sachen
wie wo du aktuell IntelliJ
für verwendest so für das Rust Plugin
oder für das
Blatter Plugin
oder so keine Ahnung
dass man dafür dann nicht mehr IntelliJ verwendet
mit Plugins sondern Fleet
ich denke das wird co existieren
aber ich glaube nicht dass Fleet
Visual Studio Code die Krone was Frontend angeht
streitig machen wird
hat er nicht mal Webstorm geschafft
ja klar du benutzt im Prinzip
überall IntelliJ
nur dass du da nicht IntelliJ
installieren musst
wenn du so willst bei Rider
benutze ich ja auch IntelliJ
teile zumindest davon
heißt dann halt Rider
kennst du eine
gute aber trotzdem performante Idee
für C Sharp, ASP, Rider
Rider ist POG das beste was gibt
weil du kannst noch Visual Studio verwenden
aber ganz ehrlich
ich merke da keinen großen Unterschied zwischen
Ressourcenverbrauch
früher gab es noch
für Linux
MonoDevelop keine Ahnung ob es den
Campbell noch gibt
oder irgendwas mit Sharp
gab es noch für Windows das aber alles
oldschool im Prinzip Rider oder Visual Studio
was anderes würde ich nicht verwenden
ich mein du kannst Visual Studio Code
verwenden aber da finde ich es C Sharp
nicht so schön wie in Visual Studio
oder in Rider
und ob es so viel sparender ist
Ressourcen sparender wäre ich mir auch nicht so sicher
Kumu war
besser
naja ich verstehe das schon
ich mein JetBrains
ist halt so ein Java Laden
die machen halt keinen JavaScript Editor
zumal das Feld von JavaScript Editor
aktuell halt auch wenig
wenig Platz bietet
früher konntest du sagen okay
Atom hat halt gesagt konnte nur kleine
Dateien öffnen war lahm as fuck
aber der Leidensdruck bei Visual Studio
Code ist überhaupt nicht da dass die Leute
woanders drauf umsteigen also sie müssten
entweder Feature mäßig was super krasses
bieten was Visual Studio Code
auch mit Plugins nicht kann
was alle haben wollen
oder sie müssen an anderweitig punkten und ich sehe da
ehrlich gesagt bei Visual Studio Code
aktuell nicht so viele Angriff
Flächen für einen neuen Editor
dass der sich durchsetzen würde
Stimmt
richtig alter der Chat ist wieder
richtig feifett alter
Leute guckt euch das mal ich trinke jetzt was
Dazu kann man nur sagen
Wie macht Microsoft eigentlich Geld mit
Visual Studio Code gar nicht
aber denen reicht es wahrscheinlich einfach schon
Marktanteile zu haben
und dass Leute nichts anderes verwenden
und letztendlich bringt das
natürlich auch in dem gesamten
Microsoft Ökosystem was
die Leute programmieren dafür was
das wird GitHub benutzt, es wird Azure
genutzt um es zu hosten die Plugins
da drin sind natürlich für Microsoft diese
zu hosten und das ist natürlich
auch eine gute Idee
die Plugins da drin sind natürlich für Microsoft
die sind dann auch besonders gut
die haben da schon was von
aber hast es geschafft
nice
so Chat wie finde ich das
ich finde das eigentlich ganz hübsch
so maximal 5 Zertifikate
dann habe ich eine Übersicht
und wenn es mehr als 5 sind
dann mache ich
Pagination
wie nennt sich das
also quasi dann
wo ist das hier
da brauchen wir was eigenes nach der
Table
müsste die Up-Down Übersicht
über der unteren Tabelle sein
ja aber ich habe mir
gedacht QuickStats ist so besser
man könnte es auch tauschen das
Zertifikat Info oben
wäre
kannst du mal für meinen Gewissen probieren wie es aussieht
wenn du aus dem Dip was um die
verbliebenen Texte rum ist ein Spare
machst das da oder was
das
ja sieht genau so aus
so wir gucken wir mal wie das aussieht
Model Page
keine Ahnung wir haben
30 Zertifikate
pro Seite wollen wir 5 Stück
anzeigen und der Rest ist ok
Reload
guck mal das ist doch schick oder
äh übrigens das geht jetzt noch auf das da unten
das bitte ignorieren
so ist es doch schick
wenn es mehr als 5 Zertifikate sind
wenn es mehr als 5
Zertifikate sind kommt so ein Ding da unten
und man kann umschalten
das ist doch eigentlich
Pog oder
dann hast du alles im QuickStats
was du brauchst du siehst auf
einen Blick Up-Down
du hast danach dein Zertifikats Info
weißt alter hier musste mal
dann es funktioniert noch alles aber es ist
ziemlich im Arsch
und
ab hier
siehst du dann das übliche was du vorher hast
für eigene Seiten
du kannst da drin machen was du willst ja
jetzt noch die Sortierung
das rot auf eins ist ja das mache ich
es ist aber noch null dynamisch
es ist ja alles hardcoded gerade
jetzt kommt ja der Trick
wir müssen den Kram noch dynamisch machen
jetzt kommt ja die eigentliche Javascript
Programmiergeschichte
wo ich wahrscheinlich wieder richtig abkacken werde
so machen wir das mal weg
das auch weg
Musiklautstärke passt oder
kann man glaube ich nicht beschweren
so wie kriegen wir das
dynamisch hin
das machen wir mal weg
ok
also
Brain Time
meinst du als Ausgebildeter
so zumindest ist es möglich einen Job als
Dev zu finden wenn man sich darin neu
naja wenn du Ahnung hast schon also
generell IT Leute werden händeregen gesucht
und Programmierer werden selbstverständlich auch
händeregen gesucht als Software Entwickler
ich finde persönlich Programmierer nicht schlimm
also mir ist egal ob einer Software
Entwickler oder Programmierer sagt was ich nicht mag
ist Coder
Coder ist sowas das benutzen nur Leute die absolut
einen Plan haben
Coder
früher haben die Leute manchmal gesagt
Code Monkey das war so richtig
richtig dämlich
das sagen nur fett Yoshi Leute
also die Ausbildung macht keinen großen
Unterschied klar du lernst
als Anwendungsentwickler ein bisschen mehr
was Programmierensachen sonst wie angeht
aber ganz ehrlich selbst die Ausbildung
als Fachinformatik Anwendungsentwicklung
alleine sorgt nicht dafür
dass die Leute sich irgendwie
die Finger
lecken nach einem
also du musst schon ein bisschen was können und natürlich auch am besten
in dem Bereich der gefragt ist
oder eben den einer händeringen sucht
das ist genauso
wie du im
so Operating
Bereich nennen wir es mal oder im
Admin Bereich Leute die ein bisschen
Windows Assistenten unter Windows Server
klicken können und eigentlich keine Ahnung haben was sie machen
gibt es wie Sand am Meer Leute da richtig
durchblicken gibt es wenige und
auch wenn du im
Linux Bereich welche suchst
die ein bisschen Ahnung haben von dem
was sie machen gibt es auch nicht so viele
Leute die in Ubuntu
installieren können gibt es sehr viele
also du musst schon ein bisschen Ahnung haben von dem was du machst
und dann ist es aktuell
würde ich sagen so einfach wie noch nie
zuvor einen gut bezahlten IT Job zu finden
richtig, richtig, ja
Arch installieren können ist schonmal nicht schlecht
also wenn ein Azubi neu ist und sagt hier
Max ich benutze Archlinux by the way
weiß ich ob ich euch heute schonmal erzählt habe dass ich übrigens
Archlinux verwende und als kommen die Leute sagen
Max Manjaro ist kein Archlinux
ich weiß nicht
by the way ob ich das schonmal erwähnt habe
Arch by the way
es ist genug ich gebe Ruhe
aber
wenn ein Azubi zu mir kommen würde und sagen
ich benutze Arch dann würde
ich sagen hier vm installier mal
zeig
Stapler
gefahren ist das wie
wie hieß der Typ ich kannte das nicht
das hat mir ein Arbeitskollege mal gezeigt der früher
auf der Baustelle gearbeitet hat
Gabelstapler Tim oder sowas
wie heißt dieser Blödsinn
noch mal Klaus nicht Tim
Klaus Gabelstapler Klaus
ich kannte das nicht
das ist ja irgendein Film von
1970 oder so
und das musste mir erst einer
Kollege auf der Arbeit wir haben
teilweise Leute das glaubt man gar nicht
also wir haben einen bei uns in der IT
der ist gar nicht schlecht also der hat schon Plan
ich meine das jetzt nicht abwerten oder so
was ich euch jetzt erzähle
der hat bevor er seine Ausbildung
als Fachinformatiker gemacht hat
die hat er auch gemacht mit was weiß ich 37 oder so
der war
auf der Baustelle da täglich Zäune gebaut
so Löcher in den Boden buddeln
Pfosten rein
und sowas
der hat Gabelstapler gefahren
der hat Zäune gebaut und danach
hat er sich gedacht leckt mich ich werde Fachinformatiker
da musste er auch mal
erst hinkriegen
jetzt ist er für Geofencing verantwortlich
nicht schlecht
was steige in den nächsten Wochen nach 6 Jahren
Software
QS
das ist das
du solltest dich mal bei DICE für Battlefield bewerben
ich habe gehört die Hamster
mit Testen nicht so
auf Java Entwickler um
innerhalb der gleichen Firma hast du vielleicht
ich bin kein Java Entwickler
also ich habe von Java noch weniger Ahnung
als von Javascript auch wenn das miteinander
nichts zu tun hat
hast du vielleicht irgendwelche Tipps worauf man am Anfang
besonders achten sollte
ja gut
ich meine wenn du umsteigst dann musst du ja schon
insofern Ahnung haben dass du diese Stelle
bekommen hast
und ich denke mal die waren
im Recruiting Prozess jetzt auch nicht
total blöde also wenn die dich dafür
genommen haben solltest du da denke ich
ganz gut aufgestellt sein
aber auf der anderen Seite
schadet sicherlich nichts
sich mal das Projekt im Vorfeld ein bisschen anzugucken
gehste in das Repo
rein weiß ja nicht was ihr habt von Bitbucket
bis GitHub sonst was und guckst
ein bisschen um dass du schon halbwegs
durchblickst was die Leute auf irgendwelchen
Daily Meetings oder sonst was so von sich geben
weil gerade
Leute die seit 10 Jahren sich immer
die gleiche Software angucken
im Quellcode die kürzen auch mal schnell
was ab sodass man nicht mehr durchblickt von was die
eigentlich sprechen
aber wie gesagt wenn du es dich abkannst
kommst du mit Java ohne Probleme klar
das kannst du mehr oder weniger eins zu
eins zu lesen klar die Syntax ist ein bisschen
anders Java hat diese
Sache mit wie heißt das
Exception oder sowas du schreibst
Extend anstatt Doppelpunkt und so
Dinger also ja
wenn du dich beliebt machen willst
sagst du steigt immer auf Kotlin scheiß auf Java
wobei da machst du dich wahrscheinlich wirklich beliebt
bei deinen Mitentwicklern aber bei
deinem Chef nicht
nein nein nein nein nein
ne überhaupt nicht überhaupt nicht
also klar C-Sharp hat
mittlerweile viele Sachen die Java
nicht hat syntaktisch
hat es schon ein bisschen aneinander
voneinander
weg entwickelt aber C-Sharp war ursprünglich
ich dachte es jetzt
so wie es
wahrscheinlich war damals auch
C-Sharp ist die Antwort
auf Java gewesen von Microsoft
die wollten quasi ein Microsoft
Java haben
und
damals haben sie gesagt wir machen
.net und C-Sharp das ist sehr ähnlich
es ist nicht umsonst so dass
es quasi du brauchst
.net runtime bei dem anderen brauchst du die
JVM das hat ähnliche
Konzepte in allem und auch in der Sprache
aber mittlerweile ist es halt so gerade
C-Sharp hat sich weiterentwickelt auch ein bisschen
in funktionale Richtung
und wenn ihr mich fragt
ist C-Sharp tausendfach angenehmer
als Java aber rein vom Lesen
und Schreiben her
ist das geht das?
kann das so beides hin?
ich habe noch nie was in Java
programmiert aber ich
lese öfters mal Java Code ich verstehe eigentlich alles
was da steht
manchmal sogar dekompilierten Java Code
weil wenn da irgendwie einer sagt es funktioniert
nicht die Proxy Settings greifen nicht
wir haben mal aus Spass
da hat sich jemand aus der
Entwicklungsabteilung mega aufgeregt so nach dem Motto
eure Proxys funktionieren nicht
und ich habe die ganze Zeit gemeint du setzt halt
die Proxy Settings nicht du versuchst
nicht ich habe TCP Dump angemacht habe
gesehen der Typ versucht gar nicht über ein Proxy
zu gehen und da habe ich damals
die Anwendung genommen und in einen
Java Dekompiler geschmissen
das heißt es ist nicht das beste Java was da
rauskommt hat mir das angeguckt
und man hat direkt gesehen
der hat den Proxy nicht gesetzt
der hat die
Settings gesetzt für den Proxy
aber der hat es nie intern gesetzt
also der hat den Proxy gesetzt
in der Konfig Datei der hat die Konfig Datei eingesetzt
aber der hat den Proxy nicht gesetzt
das ist direkt gesehen
und wenn ich als Java Noob
der ganz gut C Sharp kann
dekompilierten Java Shit lesen kann
dass ich das erkenne
dann kannst du von ausgehen wenn du Java
lesen kannst kannst du C Sharp und umgedreht
Leute
ich finde es blöd wenn ich immer so tue
als bin ich der super krasseste Feifett
bin ich nicht es gibt sehr sehr viele
Leute die deutlich schlauer sind deutlich mehr
Plan haben und auch viel mehr auf die Reihe kriegen
vor allem auch motivierter sind
was fertig zu machen aber
ganz im ernst was wir teilweise für
Entwickler haben dann frage ich mich wirklich
was die eigentlich entwickeln
kannst du x86 assembly
also meine Assembler Kenntnisse
beschränken sich darauf
dass ich auf einem ESP32
ne Schleife machen kann
das dürfte aber zwischen
ESP32 und
x86 nicht so viel Unterschied sein
was so
basic Sachen angeht
ja so ähnliche Fehler
haben wir früher auch mal gemacht
Leute ich komme überhaupt nicht so wird das nichts
so wird das nichts wenn wir in dem Tempo weitermachen
so ist das doch schön oder
so lassen wir das Zertifikatsinfo
so muss das sein
jetzt müssen wir mal schauen wie wir das ganze irgendwie
dynamisch machen
ich finde meinen cute chat nicht
ja wo habe ich das
hier
das hört sich das beschissen an
ok wo sind wir stehen geblieben
Leute
wir müssen das jetzt irgendwie dynamisch machen
also big brain
time
wir brauchen ne Schleife
wir brauchen auf jeden fall ne Schleife
also
wie vor
3rd in 3rds
3rds gibt es noch nicht das sage ich jetzt
gleich schon mal dabei
jetzt wird es wahrscheinlich nicht rendern
so wie kriege ich
die Zertifikate
computed
3rds
so der macht da immer
Leerzeichenhunde ich weiß nicht warum
return 1
BAM
massive
so
ok
das muss ich gucken
das muss ich spicken weil das habe ich
mir im vorfeld schonmal angeguckt
wie man diese Objekte kriegt
und zwar wir brauchen
root
tls infolist
die haben
oder der hat, ist ja nur einer
die haben global
der hat global Objekte wo alle Infos drin sind
die man im frontend braucht
ob das jetzt die schönste Variante ist sei mal dahingestellt
aber da
invalid type check
failed
ah
das ist, das ist meins oder
status
ahja das ist
meins
ja dann
kriegt es da jetzt raus
ok proxy
target
hier guck mal hier haben wir die Infos von unseren Zertifikaten drin stehen
so Zertifikat
Zertinfo haben wir drin
stehen dass es ein Zertifikat auf
1x1 Curve Basis ist
alles klar
jetzt Obvious
Obvious Chat also wer jetzt Fragen hat dann weiß ich auch nicht
Days Remaining
das ist sehr wichtig für uns
weil wir wollen ja hier anzeigen lassen
expired in so und so viel
Chat ist
Moment der Chat Sekunde wie mache ich denn das jetzt am besten
Chat
ihr müsst mal woanders hin
ihr müsst mal
woanders hin wo müsst ihr denn hin
links oben
ihr müsst
jetzt mal links oben hin ich glaube da ist
genug Platz
Chat wo ist der
Chat
Chat ihr müsst jetzt mal links
oben hin
mal Vorschau gucken
ja guck mal ihr könnt
ihr seid quasi nicht über dem Editor
guck mal es geht kaum
über den Editor drüber
ja das guck mal
das geht maximal über die ersten 2
Zeilen vom Editor drüber und da passiert eh nichts
ok Chat ist heute mal links oben
damit man unten rechts was sieht
also weiter im Text
so hier haben wir die ganzen Infos drinne
was das Zertifikat
alles so für tolle Sachen hat
deswegen bauen wir
da jetzt was zusammen und wie gesagt
dass ich das heute halbwegs fertig kriege
ich hab im Vorfeld schon mal bisschen
was gebaut also das ist heute
so ein bisschen wie in irgendeiner Kochshow
wenn der Koch sagt ich hab da mal was vorbereitet
mach den Ofen auf und das Essen kommt fertig raus
ihr habt nämlich vorher schon ein bisschen
rum probiert und zwar was wir jetzt machen
ist folgendes ich copy paste das mal
und dann zeige ich das
und dann könnt ihr mir sagen ob man das in Javascript
so macht oder nicht
so passt mal auf
BÄM
guck mal hier
sortierte Zertifikate
hab ich im Vorfeld schon gemacht weil ich wusste
dass ich da wieder 3 Tage überlegen muss
wie das in Javascript funktioniert
also
der sortiert die Zertifikate
aufsteigend
dass das was zuerst abläuft zuerst
also aufsteigend nach dem
Expire Datum
macht er hier
Javascript Logik also
Object Entries
nimmt von einem Javascript
Objekt
die Key Value Pairs
da draus also den Key und das Value
und baut da raus
ein Array mit
diesen Werten
und das Array kann man dann sortieren
wisst ihr woher ich das weiß
ihr werdet
nicht drauf kommen
die Antwort ist Stack Overflow
korrekt chat
ihr wisst Bescheid
ihr habt einfach
Ahnung davon ihr wisst wie es funktioniert
Stack Overflow
korrekt da hab ich das her
so und wenn ich das jetzt
zurückgebe
wir können uns das jetzt ja mal zusammenbauen
guck mal da jetzt hab ich hier schon 4 Zertifikate
und daraus
können wir jetzt eigentlich schon was halbwegs
ordentliches bauen
so
Four Serts in Serts
so wir wollen nicht nur das
Zertifikat haben sondern wir wollen das Zertifikat
und die
ID das muss man so schreiben
weil
und die ID
und wenn ich das jetzt richtig gemacht hab
bekomme ich hier die
ID von dem
Zertifikat
und ich hab es nicht richtig gemacht
hab ich es falsch rumgeschrieben
ich hab es falsch rumgeschrieben
so die ID von dem Zertifikat
hier 4 warum steht denn da
Wiki
ahja so die ID das hat mich
nicht richtig aktualisiert
so die ID hier
will ich drinnen stehen haben
Sert
Sert Info
und dann
will ich haben Remaining
oder sowas hieß das
Days Remaining
ach so scheiße wie schreibt man das
Remaining
guck mal
da hast du die Tage hier drin stehen
so bei
Date Time
will ich wie gesagt hätte ich mir das im Vorfeld
nicht angeguckt hätte ich hier 3 Tage gesessen
will ich drinnen stehen haben
Sert Info
Valid
Tool hat man das
Datum
und hier unten will ich anstatt Let's Encrypt
will ich drinnen stehen haben
Sert Info
Issuer
Oh
So und jetzt haben wir das
dynamisch zusammengebaut für alle unsere Zertifikate
POG
habe ich mir
heute nach der Arbeit angeguckt
dass wir das heute im Stream
machen können weil ansonsten hätte ich das nicht
hier so auf die Schnelle rausgefunden
ja so
und jetzt wäre das jetzt wäre das dynamisch zusammengebaut
jetzt müssen wir das natürlich noch ein bisschen hübscher machen
vor allem halt auch dass man das
pagenaten
kann
weiß immer noch nicht ob man das so richtig ausspricht
wenn die Seite zu dick ist
dass man unten das durchschalten kann
ja Urlaub ist rum seit heute
heute war erster Arbeitstag Leute
ich sag euch Pains Champ hoch 10
richtig eklig
richtig abartig
so
das hier stimmt jetzt natürlich mit den
Farben hinten und vorne nicht
valid to certificate
remaining das heißt
ich hab mir das so überlegt wir machen jetzt folgendes
ich hab mir das abgeguckt von dem wie er das hier gemacht
hat weil er macht hier nämlich
stats deswegen hab ich mir
gedacht wir machen einfach
Sert
stats
und machen dann ein Objekt was wir zurückgeben
wo Infos drinnen stehen
Up, Down
wo dann drinnen steht
Warning, Error, Count
und die Zertifikate
weil ich glaube
dass es einem Software Maintainer eigentlich ganz gut gefällt
also kann einem Open Source Software Maintainer
ganz gut gefällt
wenn die Sachen so ähnlich sind wie die Sachen die er schon kennt
Domain Anzeige
ja
ja keine schlechte Idee
ich hätte es halt so gemacht dass man hier vorne draufklickt
wo man dann direkt zum
jeweiligen Check kommt
Domain Anzeige
gucken wir mal
schauen wir mal jetzt basteln wir das erstmal
also wir wollen nicht Up, Down
wir wollen haben sowas wie OK
Warning
Error
Count
und
am Ende
sowas wie
Sortet Zertifikate
was einen Array gibt
wobei ich bin blöd
guck mal wir machen das umgedreht
wir sortieren die Zertifikate hier
und dann schreiben wir es direkt da rein
Pog
Days Left habe ich
passt
ist das schon richtig
äh warum geht das jetzt nicht mehr
ah weil ich es in Zert
Stats umbenannt habe anstatt in Zert
wo ist das
da
Days Left haben wir guck 195
und ihr seht auch es ist sortiert aufsteigend
also das was zuerst
expired zuerst
mit den
Farben und so das müssen wir jetzt noch machen weil das sieht
nicht schick aus
so
wie kriegen wir da jetzt die Infos rein
wie viele Zertifikate
was sind ich habe gedacht das könnten wir
folgendermaßen machen wir machen einfach eine Schleife
wir machen einfach eine
Schleife über alle
Zertifikate drüber
oder kurz Musik eins weiter skippen
ah beste
Hilfe Please Time
Die ID bringt
einem nichts doch die ID
bringt einem was weil
die ID brauchen wir dazu um raus zu
raus zu finden auf welchen Check wir verlinken
das ist eine gute Hinweise das machen wir
jetzt gleich das das das
machen wir jetzt gleich
ähm
wir müssten das nämlich richtig verlinken
deswegen
brauchen wir nämlich einen
ah ne nicht
iterator
brauchen ID
Zert
Monitor gleich und das muss
ich mir Copy Pasten weil ich mir das schon raus
weil ich den Vorfeld schon gebastelt habe das da
und wenn wir diese Info haben
können wir nämlich den Link
genauso machen wie hier unten da steht nämlich nicht
die ID da das machen wir jetzt auch gleich
ich zeige euch das mal
wir machen jetzt nicht die ID
sondern wir brauchen jetzt Router Link
das ist
Vue.js Magic Router Link
das ist der
in Vue eingebaute Router wo man
Seiten navigieren kann
welches Node Package gibt es eigentlich nicht
es gibt alles in Node.js
ich mein in einer Sprache
und besser gesagt in einem Package Manager
wo es sogar isOdd und isEven
gibt als Package
da kann es
eigentlich gar nichts mehr geben was es nicht gibt
so
Router Link
ID
ups jetzt habe ich TD doppelt
so Router Link jetzt brauchen wir nicht
wir brauchen ID
die ID haben wir
und der Name ist
Cert
Monitor Name
guckt mal und jetzt sieht man den Job
wo das Zertifikat herkommt
und wenn man den Job anklickt
kommt man direkt bei dem Check raus
ist das nicht Pog
so muss das sein
so
Node.js
Node.js ist
Node Modules ist quasi
schwerer als ein schwarzes Loch da gibt es doch
sogar dieses Bild
davon
so
und jetzt müssen wir ausrechnen wieviel Zertifikate
haben wir okay wieviel haben wir warning
wieviel haben wir Error wieviel haben wir insgesamt
das Diagramm ist immer noch
im Arsch weil ich die Zeit umgestellt habe
so und jetzt müssen wir natürlich auch noch ausrechnen
wie sieht das aus
mit das ist ja nicht alles rot
das soll ja grün sein
das ist grün das ist grün das ist gelb oder so
hast du auch
irgendwo einen Check
falls man was monitors kein Zertifikat ist
ja TLS
Info List enthält halt nur die Zertifikate
das hat er schon für mich gemacht
der Uptime Kuma
Maintainer
da ist schon alles drin da muss ich nichts mal
filtern
so
und wir halten uns jetzt
mit Progas Scheiß gar nicht so lange auf
weil wie gesagt ich habe mir das im Vorfeld
schonmal angeguckt sonst dauert das 30
Milliarden Stunden bis wir das hier gebaut
haben
ich copy paste jetzt einfach mal
meine Logik und ihr könnt mir dann sagen
ob das besser funktioniert
also
ich gucke jetzt
Days Remaining
oh das habe ich nicht gesetzt
Broken
also ich gucke jetzt
Days Remaining größer 30
dann ist das Zertifikat in Ordnung
Pop Schutz ich habe einen Pop Schutz
ich habe aber halt
das Headset auf
das hat nur so einen Mini Pop Schutz da kann ich
nichts großartig dagegen machen
da habe ich oben auch so ein fettes Monitor was
an so einem Arm hängt aber das nervt mich
eher
Days Remaining größer 30
dann ist alles ok
Days Remaining 7
oder größer 7
dann nur noch ist Warning
und alles darunter
ist dann
Error
mal gucken ob das von der Logik her sinnvoll ist weil ich da gebaut habe
ist das sinnvoll von der Logik
nee oder
alles unter 7
ist Warning ist Error
nee oder
das ist glaube ich nicht so sinnvoll weil ich da gebaut habe
man sollte lieber sagen
2 oder so
quasi ab 2
das ist nicht so sinnvoll weil ich da gebaut habe
man sollte lieber sagen
2 oder so
quasi ab 2
also
alles was dann
größer als also alles was größer als
2 ist und kleiner als 30
ist Warning
oder
oh mein Chat ist gerade abgekackt
Gim
1337 danke für den Sub
mein Chat ist gerade abgekackt auf dem zweiten Monitor ich habe
keine Ahnung was falls jemand was geschrieben hat was jemand
geschrieben hat
also
so
und eine Sache brauche ich jetzt
noch
so ich weiß nicht ob das die eleganteste Variante ist
aber das gute ist
wisst ihr was wir jetzt machen können wir haben jetzt
alle Informationen dafür da
so wir haben jetzt
wir haben jetzt alle Informationen da
das hier einzutragen also wir brauchen
einmal
Third
ach ich bin im falschen Fenster
ich bin im falschen Monitor ich wundere mich als warum
macht er nichts
ich bin im falschen Monitor
so
also hier wo ich jetzt Hardcoded
drinnen stehen habe 12
können wir jetzt reinschreiben
Third Stats
okay
oder nicht
warum nicht
habe ich irgendwas falsch gemacht
habe ich mich irgendwo vertippt
ach ich return das falsche
ah der Chat
der Chat ist wieder Massive
Gehirn
ist ja noch schlimmer
ach so ja gut jetzt
funktioniert die Schleife da unten nicht mehr
die Schleife da unten ist
jetzt Third
Stats
so sehr schön
komm mal drei
haben wir jetzt drei Stück
drei Stück alles okay
dann
Thirds warning das müssen wir gleich mal
testen mit irgendwelchen Fake Werten
warning warn
und whoops
warn und Error
alles klar
guck mal
ja weil das hier bloß noch 19 Tage
also guck mal wir haben drei die okay sind
eins was warning ist und null
die abgelaufen sind jetzt müssen wir hier noch gucken
dass es hier unten ordentlich angezeigt
wird
äh jetzt
könnten wir Vue.js
dieses Class
Classbinding benutzen
da weiß ich aber nicht wie es funktioniert
irgendwie so
irgendwie Class
und dann konnte man da drinnen
zum Beispiel sagen
Third
aber okay ist ja blödsinnig
Third Punkt okay
das ist ja die Anzahl
ich bräuchte noch sowas wie
Status oder sowas
vielleicht hier unten schon gemacht
ach guck mal ich hab sogar
schon mitgedacht also
Class Third Status
und dann sollte
das jetzt eigentlich grün werden
was es nicht macht
weil
warum wird das nicht grün
Tag Error
ah weil ich Hardcode und noch den Tag drinne stehen hab
null
so jetzt aber
äh jetzt hat es gar nichts
Search Status
das müsste doch jetzt
eigentlich
Ach
Warn und nicht
Tag Warn
Alter bin ich hängen geblieben
äh wie macht man das jetzt richtig
mein so kann ich das jetzt
ja nicht reinschreiben
kann man sowas hier machen geht das
ne oder so
ne
template string vielleicht
aha nice
guck mal
dynamisch funktioniert
ist das
ist das schön
ich weiß nicht ob man das nicht besser machen kann
absolut ehrenlos dass sowas geht
Tags schwarz beim grünen Tag
ne
oder
ach guck mal hier ist auch Tags schwarz beim grünen Tag
da muss ich aber noch Logik einbauen
da muss ich noch Logik einbauen
ähm okay
aber das ist ja gut das können wir im CSS machen
Leute
ich hab
ich hab Big Brain Idee
wir haben doch mal SAS gelernt vor
nem halben Jahr
wir haben doch mal SAS gelernt vor nem halben Jahr
man konnte doch
moment
SAS
man konnte doch SAS
ja
man konnte doch
was ist mit der Seite los
Alter
Flashbang
man konnte doch Sachen vererben
mit SAS
Extend
Extend kann sein
da können wir jetzt nämlich sagen
warning Extend
okay
aber das spart nichts
das bringt überhaupt nichts
außer dass es nicht so gut aussieht
das bringt hier überhaupt nichts
wobei
wir machen noch doch das bringt was
wir machen nämlich font
wir machen nämlich die font noch fett
wait ach du fast font
wait
bold machen wir nämlich noch
viel besser gleich jetzt erkennt man das nämlich auch
bold
so und der okay
tag
ist
Text
Color
FG
einfach nur Color
ne
Black
ah oben wird glaube ich
oben wird
oben wird glaube ich Tag genau Text
White gesetzt by the way das ist auch
nicht Text Black
sondern das ist
aha
BG
Primary ist das
wir müssen das hier schon richtig machen
sonst funktionieren nämlich die Themes
nicht
öh
undefined
variable okay was ist richtig
BG primary ist
okay wo sind die ganzen
special SAS Variables
drin
wo bin ich hier steht doch im Titel wir sind Software
in Game Development heute
und wir basteln was für ein GitHub
Open Source Projekt wo ich dann ein Pulli Quest aufmache
wenn es denn dann mal
funktioniert
wo sieht man denn die
die CSS Variablen
was das Bringtasch grad macht man hat
eine Übersicht über Zereplikate die ablaufen
Assets
aha
was guck mal hier
a Dark
BG primary
okay Dark BG
brauchen wir
alles klar Dark BG
Dark BG
so Text
White habe ich oben irgendwo gesetzt
das ist natürlich blöd Text White
wollen wir nicht
so jetzt ist alles schwarz
aber meine Big Brain Logik
funktioniert so nicht wobei ganz ehrlich
wisst ihr was das ist sogar besser zu lesen
ganz ehrlich das ist
hübscher
das erkennt
man besser ehrlich gesagt
als das andere
wie sieht denn das in rot aus
das sieht besser aus wenn es immer dunkel ist
oder finde ich nicht auch
komm wir gucken mal kurz wie es mit White
Theme aussieht
oh meine Augen
ist auch besser
mit White Theme
oh das war
anstrengend gerade
dass war der selbe Patch in Eats
DoktorProGamer Dankeschön für den Sub
Danke für die Subs
ich habe wieder die Hälfte übersehen heute
aber auf jeden Fall richtig Big Brain
Five Head Subscriptions heute
du musst was trinken
ich habe schon gerade was getrunken fast schon
so so ist doch eigentlich
ganz hübsch so gefällt mir das
so
es ist auch sortiert nach
Ablaufdatum
bei einem Projekt wo so oft Design achtet mag
ja das bestimmt nicht wenn es anders ist als unten
also du meinst wir müssen das
wir müssen das hier drinnen
in
da
muss das
wenn es nicht DarkPG ist
ist das was
Highlight White
wahrscheinlich
muss ich jetzt raten
weiß ich nicht
achso wir haben nichts rotes
ja
ok jetzt ist es aber so wie hier unten
ok
exellent
so so machen wir das
so ist das gut
Caller by Error ist falsch
achja
tatsächlich
das gewesen Highlight
Highlight White
so exellent
alles klar so sieht jetzt hübsch aus
hast du vor über die 3.1 noch eine Überschrift zu machen
das Problem ist wir bräuchten
irgendwas das schon in der
Übersetzung drinne ist und da habe
ich nichts gefunden
also wir bräuchten ja hier drinne sowas wie
im Übersetzungsfall bräuchten wir
sowas wie
keine Ahnung
irgendwas mit expire oder so das gibt es leider nicht
denke das ist relativ
selbst erklärend was das bedeutet
dass es die sind die ok sind
die die quasi bald ablaufen und die die
schon abgelaufen sind
so
ja passt doch eigentlich wir brauchen
noch ein paar mehr Checks Leute
wir brauchen noch ein paar Checks dass ich
gucken kann ob das mit
mehreren Seiten funktioniert
so wir brauchen noch
was weiß ich Twitch Twitch muss
noch mal gecheckt werden Web 1
save
dann
add monitor
Twitch muss noch mehr gecheckt werden unbedingt
Web 2
ok
gut weil aktuell schreibt er
alles untereinander und das wird dann viel zu lang
jetzt müssen wir jetzt müssen wir einstellen dass
der mehrere
pages haben kann das wird
jetzt auch noch mal witzig
ich will eigentlich nichts hinzufügen
was nicht im translation file ist weil
die Software ist an sich so cool was
translation angeht
und das würde ich gerne beibehalten
warum warum extra zeug wenn es
das schon gibt dann ist es
wieder nicht richtig übersetzt überall
ok
top
pagination
so das ist natürlich
obviously
falsch wir haben nicht
so viel und das model
ist auch falsch also
data
per page
ok wir brauchen
third page
und wir brauchen
third
per
page 5
ob das so
mag mal gucken
so
dann können wir das umstellen
ah
wo sind wir Hilfe
das
ist richtig per page
haben wir third
per page
records 30
und das ist hier third page
oder page
third
page
es ist
noch kein check definiert
naja
oh
wie habe ich den
Mist genannt
third page
richtig
was heißt
was hast du für schmerzen
oh nee geht doch
ja guck mal
aber
sollte das jetzt nicht
eigentlich
funktionieren
ach nee ich zeige ja immer das gleiche an
ich muss ja noch die logik einbauen
dass der wirklich die tabs durchswitcht
ja nie
das klappt ja so nicht
wenn ein check ist gelb
wenn es abläuft
ein check ist grün wenn alles in ordnung ist
und rot wenn er fehlgeschlagen ist
ich mein dass ein check grün ist wenn alles ok ist
und rot wenn alles down ist
ist ja established facts
quasi
orange hat für läuft bald ab
ich finde das ist relativ selbsterklärend
gut die tage stimmt ja nicht von der anzeige her
ach so
naja doch es ist definiert
es ist definiert es ist das wie
die notification
es ist das wie die notification
kommt und wahrscheinlich 20 tage
wahrscheinlich ist es 20 tage
das muss man nochmal nachgucken
das sind die notifications auch hardcoded aktuell
so
jetzt
müssen wir noch
ich glaube
moment leute das war das letzte
bevor ich den stream angemacht habe
was ich noch versucht habe
zu bauen ob das funktioniert
ich glaube das habe ich nämlich schon gebaut
ja lul
sehste mal
vorbereitung ist alles
oh ne falsche stelle
fack
äh
ah ne ich hab noch was vergessen
das müssen wir noch schöner machen das gefällt mir so noch nicht
oh rip
es ist broken
warum
was kaputt
oi oi oi
es ist kaputt leute
was oh
was hat er für schmerzen
was habe ich falsch gemacht
ich hab das nicht mehr ausprobiert bevor ich
angekommen bin ich hab mir gedacht das wird schon funktionieren
oder was
big brain time was ist falsch
ok funktioniert funktioniert das so
nein das funktioniert auch schon
nicht richtig
search per page was accessed
but is not defined
ah es ist ja auch nicht
search per page
es ist haha
das hab ich search per page
hab ich das genannt moment
sehste
ich bin pepega
ich hab den kram jetzt hier beim basteln
und jetzt anders genannt
ok und jetzt
jetzt aber
bam
guck mal
es funktioniert
man kann die seiten umschalten
ist das nicht pog
so machen wir noch
ein paar checks rein dass das
klarer ist aber irgendwie keine ahnung
url
wer muss denn noch gecheckt werden
keqwee punkt
ah ne das läuft grad nicht keqwee services
kennst du 7tv
amazon muss gecheckt werden
genau amazon unbedingt wichtig
ganz wichtig safe
guck mal
fuck was ist jetzt
oh
days remaining cannot be read
moment amazon kann man kein days
remaining
auslesen aus dem zertifikat
wie jetzt
äh wo sieht man denn wie kram wie lang der kram noch gültig ist
komm
ist doch egal amazon.de geht auch
expires on
das ist kaputt
ach jetzt
der hat es ja von heute richtig
kaputt
ach jetzt
der hat es ja von heute richtig abgefragt
jetzt funs easy
ok
ok das ist das ist ein fehler
wenn
wenn der irgendwie keine
info hat mit zertifikaten dann
ist proppen
tja jetzt müssen wir noch wissen was der fehler genau war
es war irgendwas null
genau es ist ein HTTPS check
aber der hat die infos noch nicht dafür
ja
du du
das müssen wir noch ausprobieren
ich glaube ein pull request kriegen wir heute nicht mal aufgemacht
wir müssen checken wenn das neu hinzugefügt wird
dass die seite nicht crasht
wir müssen checken ob der kram
verfügbar ist
also eigentlich hier, hier müsste ich gucken
days remaining
wenn es das nicht gibt
wenn es das nicht gibt dann
können wir nicht sowas machen
einfach ganz ganz dreist
100 reinschreiben
bis es gecheckt wurde
was ist jetzt das problem
wo ist jetzt
das problem hier
hä
was ist, alter
zero
warum ist days remaining
null
days remaining kann ich null
ach hier oben
das kann er nicht sortieren weil es
days remaining nicht gibt
ach so
ja guck mal amazon
amazon antwortet teilweise
mit
irgendwie einem ungültigen zertifikat
oder so, keine ahnung
man sieht ja da kann er selbst teilen, hier hat er kein problem
aber amazon kann da selbst teilweise
nicht auslesen das zertifikat
das ist, wisst ihr was, das ist ein bot check
ich wette mit euch das ist ein bot check
der landet auf irgendeiner
der landet auf irgendeiner captcha seite
mit
bullshit drinne
das ist ein bot check
aber das muss man natürlich trotzdem handeln können
das muss man natürlich trotzdem handeln können
ich dachte man kann sich drauf verlassen
dass days remaining drinne ist
das ist natürlich doof wenn das nicht geht
einfach vor dem sort nach null filtern
ja
wahrscheinlich das beste
filter
zert
alter die musik ist so komisch abgemischt
jetzt ist wieder viel lauter als vorher
das irritiert mich
so und jetzt
brauchen wir was
zertinfo
machen wir einfach so
null
braucht man das
oder
das geht ja an der herstelle gleich nicht
ungleich null
muss man ungleich null machen
oder reicht das so checkt er das auch so
ja guckt jetzt ist amazon nicht drinne
jetzt haben wir amazon raus gefiltert
das brauchen wir nicht
zertinfo ist auf jeden fall da
jetzt haben wir amazon raus gefiltert
reicht das wenn man ungleich null weg macht
aber das checkt er das
weil ich meine das ist javascript
in javascript gibt es fallsy und truthy
und solche dinger
ja das funktioniert auch ohne
in javascript genau
ok wir haben es gefixt
amazon hat keinen bock sich scannen zu lassen
alles gut
ich werde mal amazon
wieder rausschmeißen amazon mag das nicht
zu checken ob
delete
add monitor
gmx oldschool
mail shit
die wollen bestimmt gecheckt werden von mir
jawoll gmx will das
t-systems international gmbh
was
was auch sonst
telecom und gmx
ja leute wir können noch eine sache machen
das habt ihr ja vorhin vorgeschlagen
dass man anstatt dem issuer
die domain reinschreibt
mal gucken ob das
funst
ich gucke mal ob die ob die
ob die da steht
zertinfo
subject cn müsste das sein
oder
subject
cn
cn cross
ja
ja gut das ist die domain
wofür das ausgestellt wurde
und wildcard ist jetzt
natürlich für den check auch irgendwie blöd
expired bad ssl
ja mach ich mach ich mach mal auch rein
das sollte überhaupt nicht funktionieren
add bam
save
achso bad ssl
ssl
nö
das filtert er auch raus
weil diese sachen mit abgelaufen
das kann er nur checken
wenn es einmalig
ok war das habe ich schon
im vorfeld festgestellt
der ruft nämlich gar keine zertifikat infos ab
wenn es kaputt ist also
wenn es einmal ging und dann ist es
kaputt dann ist ok
also wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel sowas hier mache
das einmalig
als einmalig ok werden lasse
und jetzt
wieder umschalte auf expired
dann
hat das gecheckt
oder auch nicht
achso na gut
jetzt expire das ja nicht mehr
das expired jetzt in 133 tagen
ne das ist
also wenn es
es muss einmal ordentlich funktioniert haben
und dann runterticken dass das zählt
das habe ich ja im vorfeld schon gecheckt
das ist halt so wie das
intern funktioniert da kann ich nichts dran ändern
ich hab die infos nämlich gar nicht
die stehen nämlich gar nicht in tls
infolist drinne
wenn das nicht funktioniert hat
jo
Leute was findet ihr sinnvoller
den issuer hinzuschreiben oder die domain
also quasi
also quasi das hier
den issuer
oh
also das
machen wir kurz br dazwischen so
also das da oder das da
der issuer
ein domain ist eigentlich egal
weil man hat hier den name oben drin stehen
hat man seine
checks ordentlich benannt
dann weiß man auch was es ist
fertig
issuer ist besser
moin leute
so viel leute am start
nee brauchen wir nicht
guck mal hat man seinen check ordentlich benannt
dann weiß man was dahinter steckt
man legt den name ja selbst fest
und wenn man scheiße eingibt
muss man sich nicht wundern
wenn scheiße rauskommt
so shit in shit out
kann man sich nicht beides sparen
aber ich finde das so ganz nice
ich finde es gut zu wissen
weil letzten encrypt zertifikate
weiß ich immer dass es meine eigenen sind
wenn man es komplett
weglässt
ist halt ein bisschen mehr platz
für den anderen kram
dann siehts so aus
ist auch ok kann man auch machen
wobei ich das mit dem issuer
gar nicht mal so übel finde
finde das cool dass wir uns so
pagen können
das ist übrigens noch falsch
records haben wir nicht 30
records haben wir
um genau zu sein
zert stats
sorted zerts
length
haben wir davon und nicht
irgendwelchen crap da
warum geht das nicht
was ist hier wieder falsch
ich weiß was das ist
das ist blödsinnig guck mal
es ist nicht length
es ist count
weil
ich ja immer
in sorted zerts
nur die reinschreibe
die ich anzeigen will
das ist immer 5
das ist doch echt ganz schick
das gefällt mir eigentlich
das gefällt mir eigentlich relativ gut
7 zerts am start
1 ist innerhalb von 19
was machen wir da eigentlich für sinnvolle grenzen
also irgendjemand meinte vorhin
das ist ab 20
ab 20
tage oder so
das paint nation hin und her rutschen
na was willst du machen die größe ist halt
die größe ist halt unterschiedlich
ich mein
ne ist hier auch so guck
ist hier auch so
ich würde sagen
wir könnten es immer gleich groß machen
aber dann verschwendest du auch platz
wenn du weniger checks hast
ne ich glaube das können wir nicht
ändern großartig
so
was wollte ich jetzt noch gucken
was habe ich denn gerade gesagt
eh
guck mal
wie sieht denn das diff aus
wie sieht denn das diff aus aktuell
was
achso
naja
hält es doch in grenzen
ohje das müssen wir weg machen
plus plus
wo wir sind hier
ohje anzeige ist raus
leere dinger
wo sind noch leere
wir machen mal linting drüber
npm lint
do you mean
run lint
genau das mine ich
exakt und sonst
nix anderes
das habe ich von anfang an
okay
das liegt aber nicht an mir
die sachen sind schon
so broken
so
home
ne wie war das dashboard home
also was haben wir fehler fabriziert
mal gucken ob das überhaupt meine fehler sind
elements in iteration
also zeile 51
was haben wir kaputt gemacht
ah da fehlt ein keys
keys is id
fertig so
dann haben wir noch trailing spaces
not allowed
aha
trailing ist aber super pingelig
trailing spaces okay gucken wir nochmal
ich verwende normalerweise nie irgendwelche linter
ich weiß nicht wie man das ordentlich bedient
unexpected side effects
important heartbeat das ist nicht von mir
das war vorher schon drin
so also
unser diff ist doch
relativ überschaubar
okay to do domain anzeigen muss ich wieder
rausschmeißen domain
gelbes lock für in sieben tage
funktioniert ja nicht an der stelle
das wäre schon
cool
aber das funktioniert mit dem
da müsste ich den status umbauen das funst nicht
wer hat sich eigentlich
ausgedacht das html
commons so ein
beschissenes format haben
to do
checkinfo 0 haben wir to do
alles klar
noch mal lint
noch mal lintorn
so
alles klar sieht gut aus
ja also unser patch
wäre relativ
okay
übersichtlich
eigentlich oder ich meine
das ist jetzt nicht
wirklich viel was sich da geändert hat
ob es die schönste variante ist
der font ist anders
nö
der font ist kleiner
ja wir können mal schauen
big danger
font
font size
css pains champ
woher weiß ich jetzt was die hier für eine font size haben
font size
hier
bam
genau
das brauchen wir auch
computed das heißt
die hat er nicht von hand gesetzt
die sind einfach so
ach ne der computed
ach du meinst im browser
font size
so guck mal
alter der chat hat es wieder erkannt
so ist doch viel stylischer oder
badge
so
hier computed
font size
ja gut das ist das was ich auf pixel habe
hier 0,75
so ist das doch gut
das ist die batch class
die batch class
wartet mal
dann nehmen wir das mal
mal gucken ob das überhaupt funktioniert
wenn ich da eine batch klasse dran haue oben drüber
klar
badge
warum sieht denn das so kacke aus
das sieht viel schlechter aus als das andere
bei anderen seite so schlecht
bei anderen seite so schlecht sieht das gar nicht aus
das andere war rounded pill oder so
sekunde wir müssen
wir müssen nochmal kurz nachgucken
status component
batch rounded pill
hat der da drinne
das hab ich auch
wo ist jetzt das problem
überschreib ich jetzt ein bisschen zu viel
text colour
font weight löser
der aktualisiert gar nicht mehr
Ja so ist doch cool!
Kannst du Doku Viki empfehlen?
Ja ich finde das nicht schlecht.
Dass das das gute an Doku Viki ist, selbst wenn es dir komplett verreckt, dein Inhalt
ist halt noch da, weil es Text ist, einfach Textdateien, das steht in keiner Datenbank
oder sonst was, das ist einfach Plain Text Files.
Wie spät ich aufstehe?
7.30 Uhr ungefähr jetzt aktuell, früher bin ich immer 5.45 Uhr aufgestanden, weil
ich auch nach Frankfurt fahren musste.
Hab ich fertig gemacht mit der Zeit, aber ich wollte auch nicht später heimkommen.
So ist doch schick, schick, schickge.
So ist gut, das gefällt ihm bestimmt auch besser, weil es die gleiche Größe hat wie
unten.
Chat jetzt ist noch die Frage, in der orangenen Box, in der orangenen Box, was ist besser?
Schwarz oder?
Schwarz ist besser.
Wo hatten wir noch mal das Zertifikat eben, was angeblich alle 10 Tage abläuft?
Ach nee, alle 20 Tage lief das ab, das da.
Ich würde sagen, wir müssen noch mal, wir müssen mal kurz die Anzeige ein bisschen
faken, dass man da besser was erkennt, ob ach ja.
Einmal kurz hier schauen, was habe ich hier eigentlich für bescheuerte Logik programmiert?
Also, wenn es größer als 30 ist, dann ist es okay, wenn es kleiner als 30 ist und größer
als 7, dann ist es a warning und ansonsten ist es Error, das heißt, wenn es kleiner
als klein, das ist aber doch dumm, 2, nee, Moment, ich bin zu blöd für die Logik, ich
bin zu dumm für die Logik, Leute, ihr müsst mir helfen.
Wenn es größer als 7 ist, ist es okay, ansonsten zwischen 7 und 2 ist es genau, zwischen 7
und 2 ist es warning und unten ist es rot, ja, wie wäre es, wenn das konfigurierbar ist?
Es geht nicht, da brauche ich Datenbankänderungen, weil ich sie irgendwo reinschreiben muss.
Sind das die gleichen Werte für die Benachrichtigungen?
Das ist eine gute Frage, nächste Frage, ich weiß nicht, wo die Benachrichtigungen definiert
sind, Notification, das ist bestimmt im Backend, so, gehen wir mal kurz gucken, Server, Notification,
Sert, nee wir creppen da jetzt, Alter, mein Wim laggy hier drin as fuck, warum, das есть
173 zahlen lang, измен, Sert, Util server, eh, Lan?
Das Extendem Style ist wieder unnötig, das gucke ich mal schnell, ist das unnötig?
Na ja, ja, das ist eigentlich ziemlich unnötig, das war was lieber so. So wo könnte der das
hinschreiben? Wo könnte, wo könnte Cert Handling stehen? Yep, Minus Rill. Model Moni- Aha! Model
Monitor, das klingt doch gut. Cert, Cert. Check if HTTPS Cert Info, Check Cert, Try,
Get TLS Call if, was? Call Send Notification, was wie? Hä? Logik, also wenn es nicht ignored wird,
dann sendet er das, ja schön. Send Notification würde ich sagen, müssen wir überprüfen.
Alter, da blicke mal durch. Cert, wo taucht ihr noch Cert auf? Ne, das brauchen wir nicht.
Cert, Monitor Send Cert Info, Cert Info, Send Notification, Aha, hier guck mal, Days Remaining
21, 14 und 7. Send Notification, Send Notification by Target Days. Achso, direkt unten drunter,
das ist ja schön. So, also, if no need to send Cert, weil Target Days, ja das ist das,
was ich übergebe. When Days Remaining, ja schön, und woher erkennt, weiß er jetzt was,
wie sich sich ändert? Sag mal, macht er da irgendwelche Raw SQL Queries oder wie? Weil
es geht. Paints Champ. Notification Send. Certificate will be expired in a days. Ja,
also ich check es nicht so ganz, wenn ich ehrlich bin, aber ich würde sagen es sind
21, 14 und 7 Tage. Also 21 ist okay, zwischen 21 und 14 ist Warning und ab 7 ist ein besonderes
Warning oder was. Warum macht er denn die drei Sachen hier hintereinander? Warum macht
er denn die drei Sachen hier hintereinander? Das ist, weil er hier überprüft Days Remaining.
So, das heißt eigentlich sollte sich anhand der Days Remaining jetzt irgendwas ändern
an der Message oder so, aber ich sehe da jetzt keinen Unterschied. Es ändert einfach 21,
14 und 7 Tage vorher. Ach so, man kriegt das gar nicht? Blue Media hast du jeden Tag die
Nachricht gekriegt oder nur im Abstand von einer Woche? Einmal in der Woche eine Nachricht,
dass es abläuft. Ich bin gerade mit meinem Stuhl über das Headset gefahren, das muss
ich mal kurz rausfahren, drüberfahren, so weg. Also ich würde fast sagen, der schickt
das alle 21, der vergleicht das ja. Weil ich sehe auch nicht, dass er irgendwie die Notification
anpasst. Ja Send Notification, so und hier sagt er Sending to Send Already. Ach ja,
genau, der schreibt das in die Datenbank und wenn er das schon gesendet hat für diesen
Tag, dann sendet er es nicht noch, also er sendet wirklich nur alle 7, 14 und 21 Tage.
Ok, ich glaube jetzt habe ich es gecheckt. Ja gut, dann ist ja so eine Übersicht nochmal
besser. Also was sind das 7, also 21 Tage davor sendet er es 14 Tage davor. Da ist es
doch was wir gebaut haben, gar nicht mal schlecht. Ja bei uns sind es, bei uns sind es 7 Tage
und 2 Tage absolut funky. Ich glaube ich könnte den Node.js nicht besser, ich hätte es eh,
ich hätte auf jeden Fall.NET Backend gemacht. Wollen wir das irgendwie gleich machen den
Notifications, wenn wir das nämlich gleich machen den Notifications, dann müsste es
quasi ab 7 Tage, nee wir haben es doch relativ, ich meine wir haben ab 7 Tage steht es im Warning.
Ich meine ich wüsste nicht ob es sinnvoll ist das ab 14 Tage ins Warning. Weil theoretisch
müsste man das so machen, dann würde es den Notifications entsprechen, zumindest so halbwegs.
Alles über 14 Tage ist ok, zwischen 14 und 7 Tage ist es Warning und alles unter 7 Tage
ist Error, aber das ist ja Schwachsinn. Dann lieber so, also Error sollte es wirklich erst
ab einem Tag und drunter sein. Vielleicht machen wir es sogar kleiner gleich. Leute
soll es ab 2 Tagen Error geben oder ab allem unter 2 Error geben? Ab 2, ab 2 ist ok, dann
hat man noch 48 Stunden Zeit. Ab 2 dann hat man noch 48 Stunden Zeit, das ist ok. Error
gleich abgelaufen, ich weiß nicht, ich würde schon vorher ein bisschen schicken. Ich meine
streng genommen bräuchtest du dann eigentlich 3 Status die wir nicht haben. Du bräuchtest
quasi Achtung, läuft aus und dann jetzt mach endlich mal und dann Error wenn es abgelaufen
ist. Ja Warning machen wir ja. Theoretisch könntest du das auch so machen, dann ist
es wirklich nur wenn es abgelaufen ist. Doch ein Tag ist ok, ein Tag wird es rot, das ist
in Ordnung. Und das nächste ist dann Certificate has expired Dienst. Danach der nächste Schritt
ist nicht Zertifikatinfo, der nächste Schritt ist Down in den Services. Ja wisst ihr was
da müssen wir uns ja nicht so viel Gedanken darüber machen, wir lassen es einfach so,
wenn es denen dann nicht gefällt dann können wir es ja immer noch anpassen. Abgelaufen
wird doch in der Liste nicht angezeigt, doch abgelaufen wird nur nicht in der Liste angezeigt,
wenn er noch nie ok war. Das könnten wir noch mal ausprobieren. Wir könnten die Zeit mal
vorstellen. Also das hier läuft in 19 Tagen ab. Stellen wir doch einfach mal die Zeit vor.
Dann machen wir wieder mein NTP aus. Set NTP auf Null. Date. Auf. Was müssen wir setzen?
Es läuft am 23.01. aus. Dann setzen wir es doch einmal auf den 20. Mal gucken ob der
das checkt. Mal gucken ob der das checkt. Der checkt das, guck mal. Der checkt das,
wir müssen nur warten bis es recheckt wird. Wir müssen es gar nicht neu starten. Wir
müssen warten bis dieser Check noch mal gecheckt wird. Dann müsste der das kapieren, weil
der hat sich ja eben offensichtlich aktualisiert. Wir müssen einfach noch 40 Sekunden warten
oder sowas. Wie die Zahl der verbleibenden Tage dann negativ. Probieren wir aus, probieren
wir aus. Bisschen testen bevor man die Sachen da einreicht kann man ja, kann man mal machen.
Ja, es hat sich aktualisiert. So, drei Tage. Okay. Und jetzt gehen wir mal hoch auf, wann
läuft das aus? Ach so Uhrzeit, keine Ahnung. 22.01. Okay, warten wir den nächsten Check
mal ab, das geht ja alle 60 Sekunden, das geht ja schnell. Also das funktioniert schonmal.
Wenn es unter sieben Tage ist, wird es automatisch gelb oder orange. Und jetzt bei einem Tag
sollte es eigentlich gleich rot werden. Ja, mach dein Check. Mach dein Check. Username,
Admin. Ja, weiß. Auf, mach dein Check. Ein Tag. Okay, nice. Dann wird es rot. So und
jetzt gucken wir mal was passiert am 24. Januar. Dann müsste jetzt ja Minus eins da stehen,
wenn meine, wenn die Logik stimmt. Wisst ihr was sein kann, dass die Sortierung nicht funktioniert?
Dass die Sortierung nicht funktioniert, dass es dann auf einmal an letzter Stelle steht.
Weil JavaScript Array Sorten ja so absolute Paints-Champ-Geschichte ist. Vielleicht funktioniert
die Sortierung nicht, wenn die Zahl negativ ist. Auf, du darfst aktualisieren. Fuck.
Die, die, die, die, die, die, die. Torbe hat aktualisiert. Nee, Expire-Test. Web 1. Komm
mal, Expire-Test down. Certificate has expired. Okay, das aktualisiert nicht, muss man refreshen.
Okay, eins. Kann es sein, dass in Days Expire das kleinste, was drinstehen kann, eine eins
ist. Säck, das müssen wir gleich mal ausgeben. Log, nee, wo sind wir denn hier? Da. Log,
ne. Was brauchen wir jetzt? Cert-Info. Und dann Valid-2. So, Valid-2, wir brauchen irgendwas,
was am 22. ausgelaufen ist von KS. Wir brauchen irgendwas, was am 22. ausgelaufen ist, das
ist ja, nee. Oh, zu viel. Und Days Remaining. Eins. Warum ist es eins? Warum ist es Days Remaining?
Was, das kannst du nicht testen? Die globale Variable wird doch nicht neu gesetzt. Was?
Weiß ich nicht. Was, du meinst? Eins? Warum ist Days Remaining eins? Aber Valid-2 ist,
guck mal, Valid-2 ist 23 Star. Ah, auf was haben wir gesetzt? 21. Ich glaube, der Tag
ist noch nicht ganz um. Okay, wir sind erst mal fresh. 27. Januar. Machst du Faxen, mach
dich platt mit Achsen. Wer die Story kennt, weiß, wovon ich spreche. Searchtales, ja,
Winni, danke für den Sub. So, wir warten jetzt noch mal, bis das noch mal ausgeführt
wird und dann gucken wir mal. Also, ich habe jetzt vorgestellt 7 Tage. Also, jetzt müsste
auf jeden Fall ein Minus drinstehen, wenn da was drinstehen sollte. Aber eigentlich sollte
auch jetzt schon Days Remaining wenigstens null drinstehen, wenn wir einen Tag danach
haben. Aber da kann ich nichts dran ändern. Das ist, was das Serverseitig halt nur mal
drinsteht. Da habe ich keine weiteren Infos zu. Also, da kann ich nichts dran ändern.
Das ist doch das gleiche Problem wie bei Bad SSL. Nö. Bad SSL ist das Problem, dass es
noch nie okay war. Der Check muss einmalig okay gewesen sein, dass es funktioniert. Und
das war es hier ja. Okay, das bleibt bei einem Tag stehen. Guck mal, es läuft am 23.
ab. Ich habe gesetzt auf 27. Januar. Aber es ist One Day Remaining. Warum Nextload über
Traffic extrem langsam ist, keine Ahnung. Ich kann mir aber nicht vorstellen, dass es
an Traffic wird es wahrscheinlich nicht liegen. Okay, das ist Fail. Das ist ein Bug, was auch
immer für dieses Zertifikatshandling verwendet wird. Guck mal, der ist gültig bis erst 23.
Januar und wir haben den 27. Januar und es ist One Day Remaining. Das ist aber ziemlich
painst-champig. Hier, das ist Bug. Kommt dieses Jahr auch wieder ein Hetzerling? Ich
habe mit ihm noch nichts abgemacht. Aber ich wäre dabei, ja. Ja, das müsste man eigentlich
checken. Aber das müsste man eigentlich checken an der Stelle, wo das in diese Zertifikate
reingeschrieben wird. Ich will jetzt keine extra Logik dafür einbauen. Jetzt fällt
der Check, das ist richtig. Aber der Unterschied ist, das steht noch drinnen. Bad SSL steht
erst gar nicht drinnen. Außer einmalig, wo das Zertifikat noch okay war. Und bei dem
steht ja auch Zertifikat noch okay. Und hier steht jetzt auch wirklich drin One Day Remaining
und 23. Der hat das schon abgerufen. Die Katze ist in der Luft, stimmt, weil der Chat oben
links ist heute. Der Chat muss jetzt mal wieder unten rechts hin. Die Katze ist wieder da.
A white pepo happy. Ne, die Logik stimmt einfach nicht für Days Remaining. Die Info
ist richtig, aber Days Remaining wird nicht richtig gesetzt. Das ist aber nichts, was
in meiner Hand liegen würde. Ich meine, ich könnte das von Hand fixen. Ich könnte das
fixen, ich könnte quasi sagen valid to. Ich weiß gar nicht, ist das in Daytime? Valid
to? Oder ist das einfach nur ein String? Ich könnte das von Hand fixen, aber das will
ich nicht von Hand fixen. Wie geht das JavaScript type of String? Ja krass. Okay, date, pass,
muss ich da wahrscheinlich machen. Das will ich aber nicht machen. Oh ja, wird ja immer
besser. Ne, da dockt da ich nicht dran rum. Ich meine, natürlich könnte ich so Sachen
machen wie, wenn date now größer ist als das, dann ist Days Remaining minus eins oder
so. Guckt jetzt, aber das will ich nicht machen. Das soll an der Stelle gefixed werden, wo
diese Einträge von Days Remaining herkommen. Das ist kein großer Bug. Das finde ich nicht
so wild. Ich meine, guck mal, also der Bug ist ja überall, das ist ja nichts, was ich
gebastelt habe. Wenn, dann steht zwar hier ein Day, aber wenn du in die Infos reinguckst,
der ist um 23.00 ausgelaufen. Ich gehe mal davon aus, da wird irgendwie in der Logik,
der den Check macht, sobald das quasi expired ist, ruft er keine Zertifikat Infos mehr
ab, sondern geht direkt raus. Ja, gut. Aber dafür hat man ja meine Übersicht. Da weiß
man hier, BAM, get rekt, ist kaputt. Wie gesagt, man könnte es selbst fixen, da würde da nämlich
dastehen Null. Wo ist es hin? Null ist nicht erlaubt, Leute. Null darf man nicht setzen.
Das war keine gute Idee. Null geht nicht. Null ist falsi. Na dann. Nee, ich filter Null
nicht raus. Ich filter Null hier oben raus. Das passiert ja vorher schon. Ah, Moment,
aber das läuft ja dann nochmal. Das läuft ja dann nochmal und dann filter das raus.
Das muss Minus. Javascript und seine Türken. Ich meine, ich könnte das voneinander abziehen.
Was passiert? Was kommt denn da raus? Leute, was kommt denn in Javascript raus, wenn man
das macht? Geht das? Kommt da irgendwas raus? Ah ja, obvius. Ah, das sind Millisekunden
seit 1970 wahrscheinlich. Und das? Alter, fuck, man, Javascript. Okay, blub. Da ist
es ja jetzt wenigstens noch ein DateTime. Das ist ein Number, das ist doch nicht mal
ein DateTime, was da rauskommt. Muss ich jetzt alles allen Ernstes sagen? Dates, From oder
so? Pass? Nee, oder? Dates? Nee, das mache ich nicht. Das weiger ich mich. Du kannst
den Unix timestampen. Okay. New Date. Aber das ist doch PainsChamp. Das ist doch extremer
PainsChamp. Moment, jetzt ist es 1970? Warum ist es jetzt 1970 auf einmal? Dates. Ich will
einfach nur die Dates haben, die. Okay. Ich will wissen, wie viele Dates das sind. So.
Die Difference. Also muss ich jetzt Millisekunden umrechnen? In Tage oder was? Seriously. Boah.
Aha, 3,7 Tage. Pock. Wunderbar. Lul. Richtig Hardcore. Lul. Ah, 3,7. Moment, Moment. Minus
3,7. Minus 3,7. Und. Jetzt das ganze noch 2 fixed. 1. Null. Oh, perfekt. So. Nee,
das wollen wir da glaube ich nicht drin haben. Was? 9,0 mehr? 9,0 weniger? Äh, passt. Was?
6 statt 8. Hier. Machts auch nicht fett. PainsChamp. Leute, das machen wir nicht. Entweder, entweder
ist dieses Day Remaining richtig oder wir zeigen was falsches an. Ich werde das nicht, ich
werde das nicht in der Anzeige fixen, wenn die Infos da drinnen falsch sind. Ich bin
im JavaScript-Kurs, ich darf das machen. Sollen wir sowas drinnen lassen oder nicht? Was?
DeathFloor. Oh, das ist die Profi-Variante. Excel. Moment, Minus, Minus. Äh, ja, das
kann man. Stop at one, even if it's expired. So. Naja. M.
Kann man das irgendwie? Kann man das irgendwie noch schöner? Schöner machen? Ja, wir könnten.
Das ist aber auch nicht schöner, oder? Das ist aber auch nicht schöner, oder? Das ist
aber auch nicht schöner, oder? Ne, das lassen wir so. So. Hübsch ist was anderes. Nun gut,
ich finde das eklig, aber können wir nichts anderes machen. Days Remaining ist halt einfach
falsch, was da drin steht. Was gibt Valley 2 aus? Hier, das hier, guck mal. Also es ist
Valley 2 bis zum 1. äh, bis zum 23. Januar und wir haben aber aktuell den 27. Januar.
Fliegt es da nicht aus dem Tag aus der Liste? Doch. Macht es. Aber. Ich mein, wir könnten
sowas machen, dann, dann, dann nicht, ja. Aber richtig, das würde an dem Tag, wo es
expired aus der Liste fliegen. Lull. JavaScript, CacWade. Na gut. Das muss ich mir aber noch
überlegen. So, was sagt, was sagt der, der Linter dazu? Lint. Source. NPM. Lint. Was
hab ich falsch gemacht? Ist das exakt die Ausgabe? Relativ exakt, ja, ich hab nichts
falsch gemacht. Das ist, das ist relativ exakt, ja. Also das ist das, was im Zertifikat halt
drin steht. Das ist das, was du dir auch im Browser angucken kannst, wenn du auf die
Seite gehst. Was steht eigentlich im Browser, wenn man auf eine expired Seite geht? Clock
Error. Ah. Okay. Das muss ich, muss ich jetzt wieder. NTP 1. Jetzt die Zeit wieder richtig.
Your connection is not private. Okay. Zertifikat. Details. Nee, normalerweise steht das hier
unten. Expires on. Ja gut, da steht ja gar nicht remaining drin. Nee, valid2 ist ein
String, das man erst in Daytime parsen muss und wie exakt es dann ist, keine Ahnung. Oh,
die BigBrain Schreibweise, okay. Da braucht man keine Unit Tests. Das ist getestet von
mir. Das muss gehen. Es gibt keine Unit Tests fürs Frontend, es gibt nur welche fürs Backend
glaube. Guck mal, gibt keine Tests. Tests gibt es nur fürs Backend. Backend habe ich
nix geändert, gibt keine Tests, fertig. Ich finde das aber trotzdem hässlich, ich will
das da gar nicht reinschreiben. Jetzt ist es weg. Warum ist es weg? Das stimmt nicht,
was wir hier gemacht haben, Chat. Wir haben es verkackt. Jetzt ist, nee. Ach so, ja, ich
habe die Zeit verstellt. Lull. Ah, kein Wunder. Ich habe es schon wieder vergessen. Ich habe
die Zeit ja eben umgestellt. Ja, dann ist richtig. Wir müssen jetzt mal gucken, wo dieses, na
gut, das kommt aus dem Backend, diese Geschichte mit Days Remaining. Wir können mal schauen.
Wie macht man eine gescheite Projekt-Suche über den Inhalt in Visual Studio Code? Keine
Ahnung. Mach Crap. Da kommt das her. Okay. Get Days Between.
Genau. Hä? Aber hier sollte das eigentlich funktionieren. Wartet mal. Der macht das bestimmt
im Frontend nochmal und da ist das nicht richtig. Nö. Nö. Nö. Nö. Nö. Nö. Nö.
So, zeigt mal her. Ist da irgendein Fehler in seiner Logik drin? Weil, ich kriege nie
Days Remaining minus. Ich kriege immer nur plus angezeigt. Immer nur plus eins, lustigerweise.
Was damit macht er es wieder positiv? Ja, aber warum ist es dann immer bei eins? Warum
ist es dann immer bei eins stehen? Ja, guck mal. Ach, Moment, was macht er? Ach so. Hä?
Moment, Moment. Das ist ohne Vor- Alter! Was zum Teufel? Ach, der macht das wieder
positiv, falls da einer negativ was reingegeben hat. Falls irgendwie einer valid from was
negatives reingeschrieben hat. Also, ich erkenne es jetzt nicht. Ach, das macht eine Zahl
daraus, auch wenn es ein String ist. Boah, Java Script Magic. Keine Ahnung. Was ich aber
nicht daran erkennen kann ist, warum es immer bei eins bleibt. Das müsste eigentlich dann-
Also, wenn er es immer wieder positiv macht, dann müsste es halt sieben oder so drin stehen.
Aber warum steht da- Warum bleibt es immer bei eins stehen? Valid to get time, wenn das
kleiner ist als- Ja, hier guckt er, ob das aktuelle Datum kleiner ist. Also, ob das valid
to, also das Zertifikat, abgelaufen ist. Also, ob das kleiner ist als das aktuelle
Datum. So, und wann ich mal wieder was spiele, ja wenn es irgendwas gibt, wo ich Bock drauf
hab und was sich zum Schrieben eignet. So. Ähm, wir können da einfach mal ein Konsum
oder so lock reinschreiben. So, wo ist das? Wo ist das? CD? Server? Nee. Server? Utils?
Utils? Get date remaining. Okay. Woher kommt diese Magic Constant? Äh, das ist um Millisekunden
zu ret- Das sind, äh, das- Boah, was ist denn das? Die, die- Sekunden mal Tage mal Stunden,
dass du auf Tage kommst von Millisekunden. Was da läuft, das ist I3 mit Manjaro als,
als OS. Okay, return. Wir machen jetzt einfach lock rein. So. Ach, scheiß auf Einrückung.
Console. Console. Lock. Minus Days remaining. Und, äh, Days remaining. So. Und damit ich
weiß, dass ich richtig bin. Console. Lock. Keg W. Perfekt. Huge. Schauen wir mal. Set.
TP aus. Daten. Keg W. Lock. Beste. Und Date. 27 Sterne Uhr. Gibt da, gibt da Keg W.
Keg W. Keg W. Keg W. Okay. Schauen wir mal. Es funktioniert. Er Keg weht. Jetzt müssen
wir nur noch warten, bis er checkt. Uptime. GachiBuzz. Nee, nee, nee. Minus 3 ist von
mir noch drin gewesen. Not, not Pog. Es expired. Ist down. Ja, okay. Nice. Äh. Warum
checkt er das jetzt nicht? Hä? Checks nicht. Hätte ich das einmal, hätte ich erst einmal
warten müssen, bis es okay war nach dem Neustart oder wie? Der Keg W. Lock hat's kaputt gemacht.
Keine Ahnung. Das ist aber crap. Hä? Muss man jetzt noch einmal warten, bis es einmal
okay war oder wie ist das oder? Keine Ahnung, was das für eine komische Logik ist wieder.
Okay, Moment. Dann machen wir jetzt Daytime, NTP, NTP wieder ein. So, dann sollte er sich
jetzt ja einkriegen. Äh, vielleicht sollten wir hier noch was ordentliches reinschreiben.
Anstatt dass da Keg W. steht, sollten wir vielleicht noch ausgeben, um welches, um welches Keg W.
es sich überhaupt handelt. Es handelt sich nämlich um das, ach so, wir sind, das steht
hier gar nicht drinnen. Days remaining. Tja. Dann doch nicht, dann warten wir mal ab. Macht
der überhaupt noch was jetzt? Days between kann nur positive Werte returnen. Warum? Ja,
Days between. Wir reden ja von Days remaining. Days remaining ist ja das wichtige. Und Days
remaining macht er explizit einen Minus davor, wenn das kleiner ist als. Also da müsste schon
ein Minus zurückkommen. So. Schauen wir mal. Wann läuft das ab? Am am 23.1. Okay. Date?
23. Okay, 22. Da sollte irgendwas mit 1 oder 2 rauskommen. Da wird aber Days between aufgerufen.
Ist doch egal. Der ruft das, der ruft das hier ab. Und danach returnt er Minus Days, wenn
es, da macht er was Minus draus, wenn es davor liegt und danach. Also von Get Days remaining
muss auf jeden Fall ein negativer Wert kommen, wenn Valid 2 vor jetzt ist. Ja, Valid from
Valid 2 ist sehr merkwürdig, aber es kommt halt davon auf, darauf an, mit was er das
aufruft am Ende. Wer weiß, was er da für Parameter reinsteckt. So. Da kommt jetzt sind
wir hier überhaupt richtig? Der hätte jetzt, der hätte jetzt kommt mal Leute, der hätte
jetzt einen Tag eigentlich rauskommen müssen. Und da kam 199 raus. Was zum Teufel ist das?
Das stimmt. Ja, jetzt, jetzt wird er gecheckt. Jetzt wird er Checker Man angesagt. So ercheckt,
was checkt er denn? Passing Certificate Info, GMX. Nein, GMX interessiert mich nicht. Web
2. Nein, wir brauchen den Check für. Wie ist das Ding Expire? Expire Test hier. Ist
das noch Expire Test? Expire Test 1. Ja, das funktioniert. Das funktioniert. Ok. Und jetzt
setzen wir es auf Expire. Boah ist das eklig zu debuggen. Meine Güte. Ok, warten wir mal
ab. Nächste Expire Test werden wir es ja sehen. Vielleicht macht er das mit Valid
from Valid 2 wirklich falsch. Ja gut, wir wissen ja nicht, mit was er das aufruft. Wenn
er da Date, Time, Now oder so reinschiebt, dann stimmt es ja wieder. Guck mal mal an.
Get Days Remaining. This is the definition. References. Guck, der macht es richtig. New
Date. Link to Valid 2. Mit dem Minus for Days Remaining wird die negative Z- Nein. Wie kommt
er denn da drauf? Das ist nicht, das hier gibt immer positiv aus. Das gibt immer positiv
aus. Und er guckt ja explizit, er guckt ja explizit, ob das heute davor ist. Dann macht
er ein Minus davor, weil das hier positiv, das hier ist immer positiv. Außer er macht
explizit ein Minus davor. So, jetzt müssen wir kurz gucken. Jetzt müssen wir kurz gucken.
Ah, so viel. Hallo, T-Max, please. Ok, wo sind wir hier? Expire. Expire. 114? Ne, das
ist was anderes, oder? Ah, das ist schon was anderes. Certificate has expired. Ich weiß,
was das ist. Der checkt den Zertifikatstatus nie, wenn es expired ist. Kannste keinen Breakpoint
setzen, das ist in dem Backend und im Visual Studio Code habe ich nur das Vue.js Frontend.
Der checkt nie das Zertifikat, wenn es expired ist. Der ruft das nie auf. Das ist das. Der
aktualisiert das gar nicht. Dann ist ja auch kein Wunder. Gut, dann ergibt es zwar für
mich immer noch keinen Sinn, warum da 1 drin steht, aber wahrscheinlich ist 1 einfach der
Default-Wert. 1 wird der Default-Wert sein und der setzt das nicht. Guck mal, der Text,
also der sagt es ist expired und danach ruft er nicht diese Funktion auf, um das zu aktualisieren.
Und die 1 by days remaining ist wahrscheinlich schlicht und ergreifend der Default-Value
für dieses Feld. Joa, das wird sein. Der ruft diesen ganzen Kremple hier nicht auf.
Und days remaining ist aus welchen Gründen auch immer halt 1 standardmäßig. So wird
das wahrscheinlich sein. Das ist aber doof. Da können wir nichts dran machen. Also wenn
das im Becken falsch ist und nicht richtig zurückgeliefert wird, da machst du nichts.
Dann bleibt es halt bei 1 stehen. Irgendwelche komischen Fixes hier will ich nicht machen.
Wenn es keinen Default gibt, frage ich mich, wo die 1 herkommt. An irgendeiner Stelle muss
er die 1 ja setzen. Also irgendwo muss die 1 gesetzt werden. Vielleicht in der API oder
sonst wo. Weil ansonsten keine Ahnung. Wo kriegt er das eigentlich her? Monitor, BIM,
angle, Monitor. Days remaining. Das gibt es aber auch nur hier. Wie kommt das überhaupt?
Kann das sein, dass das Datenbank Default ist? Ich hab keinen Tag vor der Expire getestet.
Ich guck mal was in der Datenbank steht. Ich hab direkt 3 Tage übersprungen oder sowas.
Das kann es nicht sein. SQlite, Browser, RajibasDB. Wo könnte das jetzt drin stehen?
TLS Info. Kann man das nicht? Doch. Wir brauchen das da. Das ist im Prinzip das, was gedumpt
ist. Kann man hier drinnen remaining gucken? Da stimmt das, guckt mal. Hä? Nee, das ist
was anderes. Das ist irgendwas in der Chain. Days remaining 1. Ist das irgendein Default
Wert oder so? Kann man das einstellen? In der Datenbank, dass es einen Default Wert gibt
von 1? Aber das ist doch Schwachsinn. Das ist ja ein JSON-Plain Text Feld. Okay, ich
hab keine Ahnung, warum es 1 ist. Aber es ist 1. Und 1 ist aus welchen Gründen auch
immer der Default Wert. Wir können noch mal gucken. Ich hab noch eine Idee an welcher Stelle
wir gucken können. Wo war denn das jetzt? Nichts sowas. CD, Server. Days remaining.
Hier, Link. Wo kommt denn Link her? Link gleich Info. Ja, da kommt's her. Passed Certifiquent
Info. Wo wird denn das aufgerufen? Info Request. Get. Okay, das ist irgendwas eingebautes.
Passed Info. Wobei hier vorher gibt's die Felder doch gar nicht, oder? Vorher gibt's
die Felder doch gar nicht. Das ist doch so super dynamisches JavaScript Zeug wieder.
Hier wird es quasi angelegt. Leute, ich hab keine Ahnung warum Days remaining eine 1
zurückgibt. Richtig agiles JavaScript. Wir können noch mal was anderes ausbilden, um
auf nimmer sicher zu gehen. Wir setzen das noch mal zurück. Machen NTP noch mal 1. Date.
Das ist übrigens das letzte was wir machen, weil ihr wisst was jetzt ist, oder? Chat,
was ist jetzt gleich? Korrekt. Hat noch nicht aktualisiert. Wisst ihr was wir immer machen?
Ich bin ja auch blöd. Warum muss ich eigentlich eine Minute warten? Expire Test. Bäm. Heartbeat
Intervall. 15 Sekunden. Gib ihm. Gatschi Bass. Wie? Größer als 20. Na gut, 20 Sekunden.
Auch okay. Okay, 11 Tage. 11 Tage. So, wir haben jetzt 11 Tage Zeit und wir sind erstmal
ganz brutal. Wir springen von 11 Tagen Zeit direkt auf. Februar. Bäm. Hä? Ach so, 30.
Februar gibt's nicht, Lul. Okay, 26. Februar. Das ist jetzt quasi ein Monat nach dem Expire.
Und dann gucken wir mal was da steht. Es expired. Ah. Der setzt das einfach nie neu. Ja, okay.
Dann ist das wirklich so, wie gerade jemand im Chat geschrieben hat. Wir haben vorhin getestet
mit einem Tag und danach ist es abgekackt und er aktualisiert es nicht mehr. Dann bleibt
es halt bei einem Tag. Ja, okay. Dann das ergibt Sinn. Dann ist es aber trotzdem nicht
schön, aber wir können absolut gar nichts, überhaupt nichts dran ändern, außer es selbst
zu berechnen. In der Anzeige. Nee, Backhand fixen mach ich nicht. Backhand fixen mach
ich nicht. Nee, nee, nee, das mach ich nicht. Wir brauchen quasi sowas in der Richtung
hier. Wir brauchen quasi sowas hier in der Richtung, wo er checkt, ob es abgelaufen ist
und dann, ich mach das so. Ich mach nen Pull-Request auf und in den Pull-Request schreibe ich rein,
da kommentiere ich das und dann sage ich, warum ich das gemacht habe und dann kann man sich
überlegen, ob man das fixen will oder nicht. Ich finde den Bug gar nicht so, also Beat-Pool,
ich finde den Bug jetzt nicht so schlimm. Du siehst ja, ich meine es ist schon scheiße,
aber du siehst ja immer noch, ob es ab oder down ist. Also die Kernfunktionalität, die
er eigentlich bauen wollte, die geht ja. Du siehst, ob es geht, also ob es gültig ist
oder nicht gültig ist. Diese Anzeige hier, Wan-V-Zertifikat, das hat er glaube ich erst
vor ein paar Monaten einge- oder nicht mal, vielleicht vor ein paar Wochen, das ist noch
ziemlich neu. Das wir da einfach nicht gecheckt haben. Das finde ich jetzt nicht so wild.
Ja für meine Sache ist es natürlich doof, weil das überhaupt nicht funktioniert. Aber
wir brauchen hier sowas in der Richtung. Wir müssen überprüfen, ob das älter ist
und dann, oder ob wir quasi weiter sind als das, was abgelaufen ist. Wie macht er das
eigentlich nochmal hier in diesem, wie macht er denn den String da draus? New Date, Valid
2. Geht das auch? Kann man Valid 2 in ein New Date schmeißen? Ja anscheinend. Ne.
Das heißt, man kann in New Date entweder einen String reinschmeißen, den er passt oder
man kann einen Timestamp reinschmeißen, den er als Unix-Time interpretiert oder was?
Das ist die Rainbow Road Strecke, oder? Ach ne. Cloud Top Cruise Mario Kart 8. Das ist
mit dem Mario Galaxy Theme drinne. Bleibt das Console Lock Cack W drinne? Ja, ja, das las
ich drin. Das alle mal eine Runde cacken können. Boah, das ist schon, also sprich, ich könnte
es auch so machen wie der, ich könnte einfach sagen Date. New Date anstatt Paz. Dann müsste
es auch funktionieren. Dann könnte man vielleicht noch sagen Validate oder sowas.
So, super hübsch, super hübscher Kram hier. So, aus ist für heute. Heute Quest machen wir
morgen auf, das wird nichts mehr, das ist wieder ausgeartet. Obwohl das eigentlich nur
was kleines ist. Aber manchmal muss man sich die Sachen im Detail angucken. Ja, was kribbt
null weh. Leute, ich hoffe euch hat es gefallen. Wie gefallen euch eigentlich die Broga Streams
in letzter Zeit? Also mir macht es Bock. Ich weiß aber, dass manche jetzt halt auch
wegen Battlefield gucken und Battlefield kann ich mir gerade nicht angucken. Kann ich mir
gerade nicht geben. Sehr nice. PogChamp. Es gucken auch immer relativ viele Leute zu,
also ich glaube ich bin der größte, zumindest in Deutschland, der Broga's Content streamt.
Ich rede aber zu viel, weil das merke ich im Hals immer. Die ganzen anderen Broga Streamer
die sagen alle Viertelstunde mal einen Satz. Ich habe, ich gucke ja auch manchmal, ich
finde das super entspannend auch. Manchmal wenn ich pennen gehe, das ist ein bisschen
Reizuhr auf Twitch. Die sitzen dann da und basteln und sagen ab und zu mal nur wrong value.
Und dann gucken sie nach 5 Minuten in den Chat, lesen die Message, sagen nichts zu und gucken
wieder auf den Bildschirm. Ne, ich meine mit ich muss weniger reden für
meinen Hals. Für den Stream ist es besser, wenn ich rede. Säck, ich gucke noch mal in
den Chat rein. Viele Broga Streamer gehen auf YouTube. Du meinst die gehen von Twitch
auf YouTube oder du meinst die sind hauptsächlich auf YouTube aktiv die Broga Streamer?
Ne, aber guck mal im Archiv, da ist es wahrscheinlich da.
Nice, gut zu wissen. Ha, lull.
Du chebatest mich. Das ist schön Michael, 50 Trillionen.
Aber ich sag mal so, natürlich ist es mir schon lieber wenn die Leute gucken, weil sie
sich's angucken wollen. Ich hab natürlich auch keine Schmerzen mit, wenn einfach Leute
sagen sie wollen sich von meinem Gelaber ein bisschen brieseln lassen nebenbei und was
weiß ich, pennen oder so, auch in Ordnung. Das Archiv, ja das hat das Serious Max gemacht,
das ist richtig PogChamp. Guck mal hier. Mit was ist das eigentlich gemacht? Säck, das
checken wir jetzt mal. Mit was ist das gemacht? Sieht auf jeden Fall schon mal ein bisschen
nach Bootstrap aus, oder? Ist das Bootstrap? Ne, das ist, ne keine Ahnung was das ist.
Und der Rest ist was? Von Hand gewurschtes JavaScript oder OG? Das kann ich nicht zuordnen
was das ist. Ich mein man kann sich den Source Code auf GitHub angucken, wenn man will. Das
ist Agile Progas Organization auf GitHub. So und da hat er irgendwo das Archiv hochgeladen.
Django und selbstgeschriebenes JS Vanilla sozusagen. Vanilla. Ich weiß nicht mal wo
ich reingucken muss, dass ich es finde. Static? Ah hier. JS. Vanilla. Vanilla JS hat er programmiert.
Guckt euch das mal an. Alter, richtig Next Level 5 Headkram. Attach, das kann ich nicht.
Da bin ich zu dumm für. Was wird denn Contributed? Ein Patch für Uptime Kuma, mit das es jetzt
Zertifikatinfos anzeigen lassen kann. In der Übersicht, dass man weiß wann die Sachen
ablaufen. Aber jetzt muss ich echt pennen. Wir sind fertig für heute. Wir sehen uns dann
morgen wieder. Kann ich mir vorstellen. Also Leute, Betke, Wuppold, Wuppbetke, was auch
immer. Ja üben einfach. Wir sehen uns bis dann. Machts gut. CU.